welcome welcome it is friday baby
march 18th
i am joined today by the beautiful ela
cline thank you who is both my best
friend and wife
thank you
who looks great by the way i love that
sweater thank you
vintage
a little bit of a titanic uh necklace
situation oh yeah it's part of the of
the ocean was it called this is um this
girl on instagram stinky jewels
yeah
they're not stinky doesn't stink
ethan's got a pair of stinky jewels if
you don't know
i got that crotch rod
today's episode is sponsored by
hellofresh
honey and mint mobile
thank you thank you to
everybody for being here thank you to
the crew
love them all and thank you guys for an
amazing week of shows it's been a great
week of shows yeah
solid viewership
everyone's been happy having fun good
times
important announcement too
just a few minutes after we went off the
air the other night we hit 3 million
and you know we've been we've been
working towards this three million for a
long time it's been a huge
milestone for us
and we're just so happy and elo i'm so
happy to have you here to share in this
big moment yeah three million subs who
could have ever thought we would read
this could have thought such a humble
podcast that we serve here today so
three millions
who could have thought
family family family
family stop
a.b
what are we going to do if
what do we you got anything to say about
our sub count
[Music]
i appreciate it guys but let's keep it
going let's keep going hit that like
button subscribe turn notifications
we'll see you three times a week we do
it for you we want you to subscribe
thank you so much love you so much
bye-bye wow wow
yep you're a natural that's right
it's not moving
give it time mine was better
compete with that i mean his was fast so
brevity is important so you want to try
to maybe just tighten it up a little bit
please if you are a true fupa trooper
and you love our channel hit that
notification bell hit that sub button
and make sure to like this video because
we are the strongest army on the
internet the h3 podcast can i get a
whoop loop
the you know that was the f you have
like
just wedding singer vibes like out the
wazoo
yeah give it up to the bride and groom
everybody we have the best night of our
lives or what
they're about to get down and dirty
tonight they're the bride and groom
oh my god
i think zach took it oh for sure no he
found it he's got
yeah he sounds like a minecraft love you
want to give it a shot i mean you care
about the subs as much as anyone
uh i mean
my theory is just calling upon uh the
europeans you know yeah that's your do
you have the reserves the rest
please all europeans
hit that subscribe button and you know
what maybe the asians and uh the
africans can hook it up too
who knows
yeah i didn't know you were here hey
guys yeah i was at the skin doctor very
exciting
the what doctor the dermatologist oh
just to just uh tell me everything okay
i'll tell you literally everything i was
on olivia accutane for a year you were
when yeah i was still on accutane when i
started working here
your skin that looks great i mean it
does so much it doesn't look dry or like
thank you usually when you're on
accutane it gets real dry right
yeah it gets you so dry that's why some
people noticed that i
use nipple cream as
lip balm people noticed that
someone on the subreddit found it and i
was so embarrassed what's nipple cream
how could they tell oh what did they say
nipple ground it's the only thing that
works that like doesn't crack your lips
open it's nipple cream for breastfeeding
mothers so yeah breastfeeding oh i gotta
get i gotta
i gotta
you guys better get your hands on
something that stuff is like super oily
yeah
it was super oily
and you know it's safe for consumption
because it goes right in the baby's
mouth yeah no i walk around a school
with a bottle that says um safe for baby
relief for mom
i'm kind of jealous of people that
accutane like their skin is so perfect
yeah i hope that my skin stays good if
it comes back i had acne for like 10
years
most people that get accutane their skin
stays good
but it's i don't know if you guys don't
know what it is but it's like a drug you
get from the dermatologist that like
stops oil production dead
but
it dries out your skin like crazy and i
guess
i don't know it seems intense did you
have any crazy side effects from it i
honestly didn't get
horrible horrible side effects but i
watched so many youtube videos before
that like terrified me
but i had a great experience so i
definitely recommend so how long did you
take it for i was on it for like a full
year
wow that's it a whole year yeah and then
you come off and you have perfect skin
that's what the hope is some people do
six months and then they're fine some
people do like three rounds of accutane
so
am i too old to do it either should i
why would you get it just look
dude it removes like blackheads and bars
and [ __ ] yes old man perfect [ __ ]
skin it's usually in extreme cases yeah
it's gonna work don't worry you could
just stand bts
for perfect skin that's what i already
stamped bts it doesn't work [ __ ]
look at this i do this all the every day
in the mirror my skin is still [ __ ]
maybe we need to sleep like this
where's my perfect skin
hey
um little somebody uh coming to say
hello
hey it's friday
it's my boy my boy
gabe
hey
it's my boy gabe how you doing buddy
where are you first saturday baby i'm at
mcdonald's
oh hell yeah joining me
i'm having a mcdowell a double and some
fries baby what hamburger is that
it's a mcdouble oh hell yeah boy
that's a friday meal right there
hey
button baby [ __ ]
[Music]
do you like their coffee there listen my
ass buddy
i don't drink coffee or unfortunately
do you ever bring white claws with you
to when you go out to eat if they don't
have it because they don't have it
i don't break white clothes it's just in
my house or i go to
yeah i could do that
but you're a rebel nobody's going to
stop you
oh yeah
all right well listen the reception's a
little bad and i want you to enjoy your
meal but mostly i just want to wish you
a happy friday
just want to check in with you
you know pissing my ass
kissing my ass happy friday baby happy
friday baby and st patrick's day i think
that was yesterday yesterday yeah
yeah
okay
oh there's literally what's our next
holiday to look forward to
easter
wow he's so good yeah you you're you are
the holiday tracker my dude you you have
a gift for that
all right man well enjoy your food okay
i don't want to i don't want to get cold
on you but pissing my ass
happy friday
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's gold
pissing
yeah
all right enjoy the mcdonald's okay bud
and have a great weekend
all right have a good one thank you take
care of my
[Laughter]
all right enjoy buddy take care all
right
oh
[Applause]
he's learned
what he hung up that's the first time
he's ever he hung up on me
he always just hangs on the light
until i hang out that's interesting
he said my ass
um gabe
or white claw gabe on cameo and tick
tock tick tock all devices really all
platform yep
have you been elo
people haven't heard from you
yeah why does it feel like i
did we skipped last week yeah
either got sick oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
so yeah it's been it's been a couple
weeks
talk to us
[Music]
i don't know
working a lot
back to work
i i feel like i never really
stepped out of work to be honest you
were working less i was working less
um
it's just
i
there's a lot to do and you know what i
have to do it
listen somebody's got to take the reins
yeah ultimately at the end of the day
you're the you're the man you're the
person i'm telling you guys what we're
we grew fast
not super fast but pretty fast and now
we're dealing with like
the growing pains as everybody likes to
call it well just trying to be like
addressing
anything
now instead of later so that we build on
the right foundation so
it's like a lot of work just on like our
processes and the team and these and
yada yada
it's a lot yeah i mean well we went from
like seven employees to like 50 in a
year
pretty much so that is maybe not seven
at that the beginning of last year it
was probably we were in the studio but
like maybe in two years it happened for
less than ten ten yeah around ten right
yeah maybe ten yeah so you know going
from 10 to 50 is a lot of huge change
yeah
and
either is right with teddy fresh our
goal has always been
stability
longevity yeah and it's really hard
making a business is one of the hardest
things
that we've done
it's just because like
when you don't have experience
and every field is different too if you
i mean there's a lot of commonality but
like we have no
business experience so we're very much
learning as we go here
this isn't my first rodeo it is my first
rodeo actually
and then the fashion industry there's
just like so much that goes into the
making of the clothing
it's so many moving parts from
the design process to then development
then production and then marketing it's
like each one of those is a whole
department in our company
and um
it's just
the amount of moving parts that you have
to coordinate and make sure it all comes
together at the end
it's crazy right
and i mean there there there's like
industry standards there's best
practices for each department and we're
trying to learn and navigate each one so
it's almost like we're focusing on one
department at a time and then another
department falls behind and you got to
pull pick that one up
um
also covet has been a crazy thing with
like shipments delays with now the price
the inflation and prices of [ __ ] is
going like bananas
i think cotton increased by like
everything
or something everything's going up so
it's getting more expensive to say and
then make stock
to make the same stuff yeah
and the price is going up so
um it's another tough decision like
like you raise the prices but how much
can you raise you know there's a limit
to what people will pay
for the same item
without thinking like hey well
why are you raising it so much
so
all kinds of things yeah it's hard to
explain that to the consumer
when it's like oh well well you know we
just lost 20 percent margin right from
last year
i think you're like well we have to
raise the price 20 and it's hard to
explain that to the
to the consumer so a lot of in most ways
we're probably making less money
but
it's okay it's not like but like
we had a huge year last year so it's
like things are good but it's just
really really challenging oh here's that
graph of cotton prices just to give you
an idea
you know
let's see
oh wow it was at a low back and back
when we were
20 20.
what is this chart uh signify dan oh
that's price
cotton are you [ __ ] serious that's
price per pounds so it tripled almost
tripled in price since 2020.
yo what happened 2020 what happened it
was rain like all around the world or
some [ __ ] i like this
oh as far as it being that like noah's
ark or some [ __ ] well it bottomed out
right before the beginning of covid and
then pretty much yeah it's the the rise
oh it could probably demand march 2020
is when the climb started which is right
when it like the lockdown started in the
u.s and everything um
how could this happen to me
i made a mistake and you know what's
crazy is like that's price per pound
then you have to pay tariff you have to
pay to ship it everybody's taking a cut
there's a little of this there's a
little of that anyway whatever but eli
you're doing good
but always always stressed right yeah i
always stress
so that's your that's your world rick
and morty rick and morty
rick and morty greg brian rick rick
check it out this is available at
teddyfresh.com it's schmick and smarty
she's freaking sporty smack schmidt
smoke
there's the hoodie
there's another hoodie there's a
snowball
tapestry hoodie this one's sold out but
this one's so cool
this is all original art too check it
out anyway it sold out so too late
but everything else is up
[Music]
not too late losers just saying just
saying but there's still a lot of stuff
left
long sleeves
t-shirts the one i'm wearing now
teddy fresh everybody's gonna die
so there you go check it out
teddyfresh.com a wreck and morty
also the shoot was really cool we did it
in japan
edgy
fascinating
oh yeah the photos are really sick dude
edgy
cool
[ __ ] awesome bro
did i mention sick
no
i don't think he did it's sick
look at that sick
where was this in tokyo
i
don't know the exact location i believe
so though probably tokyo
cool
edgy
his face is tatted up
japan is all about the respect you know
it's interesting that face tats like are
in so in i know how interesting is that
who would have ever thought face tats
would become a thing
but i actually don't hate it i think you
know looks like no i think it looks cool
think about getting one huh you thinking
about getting one
yeah i was thinking about getting like a
big old [ __ ] like skull here
like right in the center yeah it'd be
cool to like get like a like a third eye
like your third oh third eye
you're enlightened like just a
really realistic eyeball right in the
middle of your forehead yeah i'm super
into mysticism so i feel like that'd be
appropriate
look at him tragic something like that
maybe
maybe like fallen angel
oh
oh my oh airline i like damage
or or what about perfect hairline
airline
with like a dotted line that follows
your airline king [ __ ]
what if it does like
very subtly recede though oh yeah you're
kind of like out against the line
against the line you'll be able to
measure you know you know you have a
measuring stick when you're dead
it'd be like that but reverse every year
you could do a new mark it's like the is
like the ocean or the lake
receding that's right
i like the idea of writing something on
my hairline
tragic
maybe small [ __ ]
that'd be first
that would be first nobody nobody's
probably ever done that on their face
yeah really sad
maybe
low iq
yeah thinking about a face stat
definitely
tattoos are very in in general yeah they
are
i'm
definitely slightly jealous when i see
people with tattoos really you want tats
but at the same time i don't think i can
do it
just don't
i don't have that urge to like get
something permanently on me
i was thinking about turning my belly
button to like a goat's butthole yeah i
remember that
i think you should do what uh what pete
did which is in our story we're talking
about today and and just get ila's name
branded into your skin yeah
pete davidson yeah you did that with cam
yeah that guy moves too fast that's
probably in every relationship he
clownfucks
and then it's like you gotta slow down
are you gonna scare them off get get
this that's the third
it's the third kim ted well that one's
not a tattoo it's a brand he has two kim
kardashian tattoos and now a brand on
his skin as well dude you got a chip
for like a month
i remember when he was dating uh
what's her name
yeah ariana he was like i'm in love i'm
gonna marry her they've been together
for like one year and then she dumped
him the next month because you came out
too strong bro you guys stop that [ __ ]
somebody gotta talk to this man it's bad
they say never get your partner's name
tattooed
that's good advice my ex
got my initials tattooed no way yes oh
my god
very sweet girl does she still have them
she try to cover them up but they keep
bleeding through
i don't know where they're at they're
still there now
bleeding through like she put like
hearts over them
and the aaa keeps how long were you guys
dating
uh
two and a half years two and a half
years and how far in did she get the
tattoo towards the end towards the end
before she started
and when she got the tattoo did you know
the relationship was basically over
oh no i would never let her get it no
just because you said it was towards the
end so what happened there because it's
there's a lot of time and then it just i
started working at a restaurant
oh you fell in love with lena no no no
no no no i just like this was years
before elena but uh you know i just once
i started working at the restaurant just
things were we were young she just got
more jealous about me working with
girls and this and that but
did you cheat on it no no no i would
never island
okay interesting nobody's ever tattooed
my initials for the record ela you're
thinking about a tattoo idea people have
your your face tattooed
that's true people do have my face off
that's pretty yeah that's pretty big but
i'm not [ __ ] them
not yet not yet
what would you get tattooed
ethan klein yes okay
that'd be sick that'd be hardcore
i do bet if you started tatting your
face people would notice you more like
the magazines would be like ooh who is
she
this edgy new designer she got cats on
her face
and he just dressed the same like real
sweet and cute and then you just tattoo
like mom all right a mother of two yeah
they better fear you
for sure tear drops i mean yeah i would
probably do stuff like that like our
dogs or i like dinosaurs because of
theodores i would tattoo that
that's good
but i feel like i will get tired of it
like in two years
that's probably true
i think the only thing i would ever tat
is like a memorial tattoo
hmm
of who like if somebody died yeah
yeah
that's what i mean
i mean yeah so like if the dogs die
when the dogs die okay i'm gonna tat
them
but other than that something that was
like a very deep meaning i'd probably do
i'll definitely get a shred or an
alfredo tattoo
someday
[Laughter]
that actually looks pretty good
who's got tattoos here i see the chat
curious they want to know olivia has
and cam i think are the only three with
tattoos maybe i know you're tatted up
you're like you're like such a bad boy
you've got like flames on your arm you
drive like a challenger
you try to be a bad boy no
yeah you do kind of like a nerd that
hides to be honest lina
yeah i don't know how olivia has so many
lina are you here yes
no
i want to ask if she's in the bad boys
lena
like i've always wanted to like do my
full like bottom of my arm
um but being from like a traditional
family i was a little worried about it
yeah but lena like her family's really
traditional and like when things start
to get serious with her she's like if
you want to do it i think you should do
what you kind of convinced me to go
through with it because she likes bad
boys
i don't know i gotta ask her about that
and your family was okay with it hell no
no no which is funny because my dad has
a bunch of tattoos but
yeah he does
how does that go together and i don't
know wait what kind of tests does your
dad have dad tats like what's a dad that
like a heart would have stored in it no
it's like
like uh
tribal tats he does have like a tupac
tattoo wait your dad has tried has
tribal [ __ ] around his arm on his arm
no no it's like in the same place he has
no one knows about this but he has one
like in the same place tupac does and
it's like you think oh that box is dug
life
yeah yeah
i don't even remember what the hell it
says something like lawyer alive
no it's like
might have had a bad midlife crisis this
is like
enraged or something enraged
whoa
my dad my dad's from the street my dad
my dad's had a rough
enrage
maybe that's a good hairline tattoo
and rage
don't cross me buddy how about that
what are your cats olivia
i have a few um
i got one the day i turned 18.
my mom asked me if i wanted one and i
said yes because she also loves tattoos
olivia um so i have like a rose on the
back of my neck it was the first tattoo
i ever got
and then the second one i have
in italian it says um your feelings are
valid on my arm wait why italian because
i'm part italian because it's just how
much italian um
like half i think at least half
yeah
i'm pretty italian who's italian in your
family your mom or your dad my mom and
my dad my dad's mom
you come into the studio
50 italian you don't say nothing to
nobody
i like to keep it on the dl sometimes my
you know my sons
you know my boys they're five percent
italian
yeah
that makes me a don
yeah that means we all have a lot in
common
what's your favorite italian pasta
i'm a fan of uh
spaghetti
spaghetti
you like the cake that's a great one you
like the kata peepee
i remember catching pepe
big fan one time before the show you
were talking about i think it was the my
way tattoos and how it's the stupidest
[ __ ] tattoo to get or something my
way wait which one is that
yeah ethan's like the people that get
the tattoo my way
wait i don't remember that you're saying
something my way like frank sinatra was
my way oh no i said people who sing that
song i did it my way is a red flag oh
okay okay and if you go to karaoke and
you start singing i did it my way every
person i've known who does that
mentally unstable and i have that
tattooed on me
it did
i did it my way no no i just my uncle
who was in world war ii and was i was
very close with he passed away but his
favorite song was my way by frank
sinatra and so i have a tattoo of the
plane he drove in world war ii and this
is my way on the side how do i know
that's not a burger oh my god
burger king oh iowa isn't it your way i
don't know your way maybe you're right
well that's okay so you're you know
it's a disgrace to ap but you know what
i'm saying you guys but you know those
people at karaoke
every time i did it
my worry
the alka
uh cam sent this this is uh
is this your first tattoo cam is that
what you sent this is his latest tattoo
oh later got this yeah he got this i
remember while he lived down here it's a
bat
why'd you get a bat cam
uh i just like better memorializing uh
corona look timeless but i want to get
way more
wait what did you say
uh cam what did you i made a rude
comment and interrupted you sorry go
ahead
oh wait sorry say that again
oh boy
why did you get the tattoo
oh because i like it okay it's pretty
hard cool okay you have any uh
is there something with bats or you just
like you like this image
um i think it looks cute and vicious is
the uh cute and vicious
cameron is very nice
you want way more
well cam's gonna be all tatted up by a
couple years let me just say i would
definitely get a uh face down if it was
socially acceptable
i can't hear you yeah this is mike
i think it is socially totally socially
acceptable
like i mean i guess
yeah sure but if i didn't have to worry
about work i would definitely get face
stats
what would you put on your face
um
are you already your bosses said they
accept it you can get it man
wait what do you what do you want to put
on your face
uh i don't know i'd to be determined
like i said i want to let me fill up my
arms first and then all the work from
there also that's part of my my problem
too i feel like if i went for it i would
end up wanting like a full sleeve
i didn't know that about it yeah
if i did it
because i think once you have one you're
like wait i gotta fill here and then
it's like wait it's off balance i gotta
put something in that is exactly my
reason for never getting yeah because if
i got one it would break the seal and i
would have to go full sleep i actually
just agree i like like how olivia has it
where it's just like one day
i don't think i would be able to
stop there okay i command olivia she has
a bunch of finger tattoos and those are
by far the most painful i don't know how
really she went through this i have a
little one on my finger and that that
one killed like huh just a real tiny one
but she has a bunch i don't know how
does it compare to eyeball tattoos
olivia
wouldn't know
so this is what i'm plotting something
like this
but it just says ela or something
we should do it let's do it on the show
now
i would do ethan if you do either
god
imagine that people think we're [ __ ]
crazy
[Laughter]
people would love it
yeah i think i'll get tattoos someday
but only like to to like uh
you know
if
i don't want to say it but like let's
just say if i died if you [ __ ] died i
would tattoo you
okay
i don't think about such things but i'm
just i know that that's what i would do
and i would probably put it on when you
think about if you would do it when
somebody died why not do it when they're
alive because like things like the dogs
no because i put it on my hand
somewhere like that not hide it so that
like it's always at the forefront of
your my mind
here you're i don't i'm with you every
day
but like if you perished
if you perished why because that why is
that inappropriate this no what zach
played the animals
you're trying to say this very heartfelt
thing no it's fine it's funny
but like if you perished untimely
i wouldn't want to ever forget you
in any moment so i would put it
somewhere like this and same with the i
would probably put the dogs here
you know what i mean
so it would always be at the forefront
of my mind
i would do the same you would
let's do a pinky promise yeah
for sure
all right um we're at uh 30 minutes
shredder so we should do our
[Laughter]
you're out of my inheritance
um yeah so we should do our ads and then
we have uh our first of two
guest callers
yeah who was calling in we've got the
the peanut butter [ __ ] yes the peanut
butter [ __ ] allegedly allegedly well
we don't know and that's why we need to
speak to him okay
and then who else is calling in uh later
we have a long requested segment on the
show from the audience we have an
astrologer calling in
to talk to us
about
the stars i assume they're going to read
us our uh
our charts our charts yep she's got all
of our info that should be interesting
and this is this person is the real deal
she's
accurate
she is tuned in 100 accurate
everything that she says becomes 100
true
uh 100 of the time
um and
uh
if
people are i'm worried about doing this
because people can get so mad at me
because i know people love astrology for
some reason it's just
it's it's
a straw and i know people can get so mad
at me for this segment because i bet a
lot of people in the audience
love astrology or they'll be like listen
i don't take it as gospel but it's just
interesting to see and read it and
inform my week
not my words
anybody on the crew here
like one that would take it
somewhat seriously several yes uh i know
um
cameron is uh
and sam and olivia right really
yeah
i dabble a little bit she dabbles yeah i
like to know things about myself mm-hmm
even if they're below women i'm just
gonna say it women love say it they
don't say it take it back women love
astrology do not say that it's very
insulting to cam that's well and then
there's cannon insulting to me
it's because i'm a woman it's a
generalization and i think it's [ __ ]
true don't generalize sam are you into
astrology
exactly she said i think
i don't like base my life decisions off
of it or
whatever
um
men are generally into sports and cars
ethan that's true
are you you're not that's why it's a
generalization
if you could if you could like take the
whole audience of astrology how many of
the guys here are into sports and cars
listen
i see one hand
i'm kind of into cars not really sports
my point is this hilo
if you could get if astrology was a
youtube channel and you had all the
analytics you'd be coming out with like
70
women 30 men i feel like in the gender
demographic of people visiting that
channel can i get a whale well why don't
we just definitely speculating why don't
we ask this is uh who will be speaking
with her oh she'll get she has the
analytics she could tell us right her
name is marin uh she has 1.2 million
yeah she's popular and by the way i was
and i thank her for coming on we're
gonna have fun i'll be respectful and
i'm very appreciative she's calling him
but she's a big deal too that's a lot of
followers i guess indeed
but that's later because first we need
to do our ads and then we need to speak
to the peanut [ __ ] yeah we gotta talk
to the p we gotta talk to the peanut
butter [ __ ] before we get to that
dude's more likely to [ __ ] peanut butter
for sure right right oh yeah oh like
and does that bother you if that's a
generalization ela
i mean i don't know if peanut butter
[ __ ] wait hold on if peanut butter
[ __ ] was a youtube channel yeah the
analytics would report well
90 to 95 percent meant you agree yeah
i have to admit that i i'm not familiar
with this topic at all yet well just use
your but just like what you know of the
world then yes it's probably man exactly
you see
the defense rest is case okay
just saying
yeah no
all right let's take our sponsors we
have so much to get to action-packed day
on this friday march 18th
what a good time starting with the
favorite hello fresh
hello fresh you get that farm fresh
pre-portioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes
right to your dorm step skip the trips
to the grocery store count on hella
fresh to make home cooking easy fun and
affordable and that's why it's america's
on one meal kit
look at this burrito what's in it is it
food is it beans rice or is it uh
cardboard
frankly
it could be inedible
ingredients this is of course abey's
burrito
it's the world's favorite av is
quesadilla right right that that was a
big red there's too many burrito
accounts i think we have to keep it a
burrito at this point now there's like
abs chin beard too like they're just
playing off the meme
well this is uh we've debated it this
we've decided maybe the world's most
famous burrito definitely my favorite
burrito oh thank you there's not much
contest or you know challengers
there's david dobrik's chipotle burrito
and justin bieber's the size i never
heard of those exactly did you see what
he revealed on instagram the other day
maybe i don't know if we want to talk
about that but
tell me about it
i revealed uh
something oh you have a second uh you
have a second angle
yeah let me see it you have a second
angle today i'm going to real to you
that there was actually another angle
what
[Music]
oh my god yeah i mean that that that
that's good it doesn't give us much
information either
so why did you choose this one and not
the other angle
i
i just felt like the contrast was a
little better on the first one the color
correction it's it's the better photo
yeah you made the right choice yeah it
looks like the grill marks look a little
better yeah i love that there's a second
angle though is there any other angles
you're holding back on us we'll have to
keep
finding out more each week stay tuned
subscribe turn that like button
that's interesting our notification
button
i see the song you chose for that reveal
is titled geek music
awesome thank you we out here
here's actual food that people who make
who actually are trying to uh
show that the food is delicious how dare
you why
why'd you say it like that
what did i do wrong i would eat that
burrito how do you know you don't know
what's in it thank you it might be
snacks it might be like literal
thumbtacks how do you know you would eat
that burrito all you see is a tortilla
it could be literal dog [ __ ] right
you can't say you would eat that burrito
i'm gonna make everyone in here burritos
except you ethan you're gonna regret
those words it's fine
i'm just saying you can't sit here and
commit to eating an unknown burrito
life i'm committed it could be human
fingers
just saying bro could be foreskin just
saying right
you gotta know what's in it
it's human fungus
anyway
here's some delicious food that pooper
troopers at home
have cooked up and all look so good
that's what hellofresh is so awesome
they send you a box to your door it's
got dry ice it stays perfectly
refrigerated until you get home and pick
it up it's got pre-portioned ingredients
and instructions how to make a
nutritious and delicious home-cooked
meal
it really is
a home cooking renaissance
also you can learn a lot about cooking
myself i stepped up my meat cooking game
a lot since i started yellow fresh
there's a couple of tips in there that i
implemented
and changed my game
and you know it's even
some they even say it's cheaper than
grocery store shopping because there's
no waste
you just get exactly what you need for a
perfect meal it's cheaper than eating
out and it's cheaper than just buying a
bunch of aimlessly buying a bunch of
groceries uh
you know what i mean
they've got a whole diversity of menus
including veggie fit wholesome family
friendly gourmet
give it a shot it's fun it's great it's
delicious
such a good time guys
uh and also go to hellofresh.com after
dark 16 and use the code after dark 16
for up to 16 free meals and three free
gifts that's
after dark hellofresh.com
use the code after dark sixteen
uh thank you thank you to hello fresh
america's number one meal kit
good times baby
and another favorite
it's honey
do you like free money
yes we can do you like free money yes we
can
i don't know why it turned into like
like can i kick it oh yes we can
can i
install honey for free yes we can this
is like such a bastardization of uh
how dare you horrible
insulting yeah delete it they're gonna
sue us
de la soul right
yeah
yes deleted the same people isn't it
can i
kick it yes you can anyway that's a
tribe right
a tribe called all right tribe called
isn't they law the same people de la
soul no
i think it's the same people really i
don't know i don't think so
similar people
we gotta fact check that what
no crossover i'm just seeing a little
difference
i'm seeing featuring a tribal taylor
soul featuring a tribe called quest
what do you have to say about honey you
got to check your fan
members names
anyway our chat probably knows they'll
tell me if i'm wrong right we we're all
telling you that you're wrong
it's not the same person
it's not they're saying what the [ __ ]
ethan okay no no no
[Music]
just
for anyone at home that was confused
anyway
honey is a fantastic way to save money
online um you know
uh they can also it's not only on the
desktop anymore ella it's also on the
iphone wait really yep they did finally
get that on my phone you know it doesn't
matter where you're shopping honey is
pretty much gonna save you money
anywhere i'm talking about
technology clothing shopping ordering
out it's all hooked up and what it does
it scours the internet for coupon codes
that are available and automatically
applies it at checkout and a simple few
clicks it's free and easy to install
guys it is insane
what is this 12 bucks post pulse mates
super simple ordering some food on post
are you freaking kidding me on postmates
yeah
you don't even have to think about it
are these all mine yeah
when did you see you just ela just
periodically sends me uh the discount i
was ordering on my computer one time and
then it popped up and i was like okay
sure let's see and it actually worked i
would never expect like on food i know
that's so good imagine you're shopping
at your favorite site when you're
checking out honey pops down click uh it
says apply coupon boom about it being
about a bane forget about it few seconds
saving money free money price drops
forget it
and now it doesn't just work on the
desktop it's on the iphone too activate
it on safari on your phone and save on
the go if you don't already have my
honey you could be straight up missing
out and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting this
show i'd never recommend something i
don't use uh get honey for free at
joanhoney.com that's joinhoney.com
after dark i thank you
and finally
dan's favorite
phone company
oh wait i have an excerpt here for maybe
the native tongues were collective
in the 1980s and early 1990s hip-hop
artists
wait the native tongues yeah that was
the name of a collaboration effort
between de la soul
and tribal quest called you same people
bro
i'll accept my title of hip-hop head now
can i kick it with the hip-hop heads yes
i can
what are we talking about mint mobile if
saving more and spending less is one of
your top goals for 2022 why are you
still paying insane amounts of money
even mo every month for wireless
switching mint mobile is the easiest way
to save this year and the first company
sell premium wireless service online
only mobile lets you maximize your
savings with plans starting at just 15 a
month dan tell them about your [ __ ]
phone
do you hate this [ __ ] paper waived
out version of the song
yeah no it's sick
uh yeah mint bobo baby
same as the big guys use the same
technology same network you know who i'm
talking about won't say their name and
they're addressing they'll be
disrespectful or sponsored but [ __ ] them
you know who i'm talking about hey you
know you know what i'm talking about now
don't make me come over then
the same network so you're getting the
same same service at a fraction of the
price 15 bucks instead of 100 bucks it's
the same [ __ ]
that's it
let's hit it that's it for people
looking for extra money this year mid
mobile's offered premium wireless for
just 15 bucks a month and by going
online only and limiting traditional
costs retail mint mobile passes
significant savings on to you listen i
don't care how you do it just do it
you know
they're like here's our business plan
we've eliminated brick and mortar stores
and uh cut the bat and well and going
into the fourth quarter no just just
give me the price
fifteen
dollars
all plants come with unlimited talking
tax high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network use your own
phone with any mint mobile plan keep
your same number along with all your
existing contacts with mobile choose the
amount of monthly data that's right for
you and stop paying for day to day and
now we have
switched my mobile get premium wireless
service starting at just 15 bucks a
month to get your new wireless plan for
just 15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com
h3 that's
mintmobile.com3 cut your wireless bill
to 15 bucks a month at midmobile.com h3
thank you thank you peace and love all
right what was that like a 30 minute ad
read
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
damn that is sick it's like a sonic
level
it's like the casino level on sonic
blink boing boing
[Music]
um
all right what do we got we have so much
you guys
let's see jared leto's back
why do people still hire him
wait um
we got we have a call lined up yeah he's
he's in the waiting okay so wait let's
get on to
uh craig
well formerly known as craig we got to
do a little background on him first yeah
so this is our boy craig oh wow he's
he's really into
uh peanut butter okay and now his
content is like specifically peanut
butter focused right amy or who who's
generally or is that
it's not really he he loves fortnite and
peanut butter and just making having a
good time yeah so his name is formerly
known as craig yeah so it's a bit of a
queen thing
you might say
like the artist formerly known as
prince i meant prince you guys queen
prince same thing well it's the same
same family
literally
so nothing beats first thing in the
morning don't worry this was an
untainted jar there's nothing like
spoon in the peanut butter
first thing in the morning when you wake
up
peanut butter
now there's debate around
what untangled
yeah what does it mean right so
it's
this was the first one where it's like
okay what what does that necessarily
mean and then you go deeper and deeper
but it's the question is still not
answered although there is some evidence
that you know yeah could be there's some
circumstantial evidence that
he might be putting his dick in on tour
yeah maybe yeah so here's part two this
is uh
oh he's got a fatty if that's the kid
[Music]
wait so so
the
look people made after seeing how far it
went down
when you're when you're snowed in i
can't wait till friday night
i mean why would he avoid the
huh it went down
so
you would think
[Laughter]
you would think if he was eating it you
why avoid the edges
right um
well
we
we've all been provided with a jar of
peanut butter you'll see uh ela to your
right um there are two jars can i get
one of those yeah i mean i thought maybe
we could
try and see if it's scientifically
possible to create what he did yeah i'm
sure you could do it you want to take it
out and then spoon around right oh he
was spooning something so
so it sounds like you think it's still
not definitive like that's not that's
not
admissible no
no that's not proof
so here here's another one
fortnite
this is one of craig's uh i i think his
most popular video
this one yes no the first one had more
about the
yeah okay or one of his more about there
so so so this is wacky fortnite yeah all
right
wacky fortnite
wacky fortnite
walkie fortnite
say it three times and you'll win your
next match
oh that's yeah that's good is that
astrology
i think so maybe i don't know but i
tried it it worked i did it really me
loving ian pulled a dub yeah no
you know who i've been noticing has been
pulling mad dubs is sam
sam is a straight gamer girl really yeah
she was posting like
are those solo dubs sam or team dubs uh
solo oh dude she's insane good i'm so
addicted to that game you're getting so
bad i found myself on fortnight weeks on
reddit i was like i'm down cataclysmic i
know
shouldn't there be like a hold on this
is super shouldn't there be a lid or
something we took them off ted okay i
have to do it on the show nobody put
their dick in this right yeah i did test
some last night but i don't think that
this is untainted right yeah i believe
it's something to do it is very liquidy
it's got a lot yeah
i tried stirring
can y'all just get like the skippy [ __ ]
you don't like sprouts sprouts bro this
is creamy no stairs yeah i don't know
listen
that's just that's not no stir that's
not nice i stirred and still liquidy
don't put no stir well for the purposes
that we're discussing today you might
want that actually listen i get it you
want that good [ __ ] where you have to
were you the oil [ __ ] no i don't want
that just you know what i mean
eating my peanut butter with whatever
[ __ ] they put in where you don't disturb
it isn't gonna be the [ __ ] that kills me
when i die trust me
tastes good though
[Music]
all right well so i mean the other angle
to all of this is this guy is declaring
that friday is peanut butter fridays
which
directly
goes against
established cannon here on the h3
podcast which is that it's white claw
fridays
that's interesting that could lead to a
conflict but that's kind of what i was
thinking is we should speak to craig
today and then maybe in the future we
can
set up a little
verses
this one you can't do it
what he
it just no it's too liquidy you're
liquidy
to stick your dick in or you need to
liquidate you can't no you can't create
that
that tunnel yeah we have an expert on
hold should we should we ask him
yes
i'm gonna have to try to convince one of
them to change their days
right
yeah they're saying maybe peanut butter
could be thursday anybody thursday or
saturday thing right yeah let's talk too
formerly known as craig okay i'm gonna
bring him up first thing we need to
establish is what do we address him as
uh i'm setting it up right now just
stand by
so craig um he also goes by craig shorty
bush
craig what
craig shorty bush
greg shorty bush yeah brush
craig shorty brush
craig are you there i hear you yes i am
let me let's just pull up your video
thanks for calling by the way it's great
to talk to you
it's an honor thanks for taking the time
well my pleasure's mine
so it looks like your camera's off craig
could you uh
you turn that on
we're just waiting for craig to connect
it there he is there it is
craig thanks for calling great
[Applause]
looks great
so what first of all my first question
is what should i address you as because
your handle is formerly known as craig
well i've had like two or three accounts
my first account was craig shorty brush
but there's something about tick-tock
guideline violations or something like
that i'm not really sure oh
i had to make a new one
so you were formerly known as craig so
you are correct
yeah okay
okay great
so craig obviously we're fascinated by
the
the love of peanut butter
how long have you is peanut butter your
favorite food
no actually it's not lasagna oh
what's your favorite food
lasagna oh
well i'm italian
are you italian
no just like lasagna
how the peanut butter thing happened
though was i was bored one friday night
and i got one of those ants that always
brings you stuff
and one day she brought me a jar of
peanut butter so it was a friday night i
was like
um it's friday night
yeah this jar of peanut butter
okay
so that's not i just read the
i just read the comments and it went on
from there
oh so you're kind of just playing into
the whole peanut butter meme so do you
even like peanut butter craig
it's okay
dude i'm disappointed this is really
changing
everything
wow
okay craig is that one your favorite
brand
yes just creamy don't get crunchy yeah
that's good yeah that's what i would
have got you know these guys around here
they got the fancy stuff they got me
this weird [ __ ] that's like
got the fat at the top you got to mix it
in
not good i thought you poured it out i
was like
oh yeah you saw that
well craig
there's a there's speculation
that uh
you put your dick in these in these
peanut butter jars is that
is that something that maybe
is that something that you do perhaps
i can't answer that without
a lawyer present
[Laughter]
and you're afraid of the legal
ramifications
yeah i might get another guideline
violation or something oh if tic-tac
actually knew what i was doing
[Applause]
because there is this photo here this is
basically our best evidence to support
the claim
i'll pull this up maybe you can see it
there yep recognize it yeah yeah
now
what caused that indentation in the
peanut butter
what caused that
a big long slum
so you did put your dick in it
maybe
interesting being a little cagey but i
mean that seemed like a confirmation
and and is that a sexual satisfication
or just like uh just like the experience
of having your dick covered in peanut
butter well when you're bored and you
don't got no going around you know
it's friday night
it is friday night
it's friday night what are you gonna do
you gotta compensate somehow i gotta say
peanut butter doesn't seem like the best
lubricant if i had to guess but
you when there's a will there's a way
exactly we all have our own opinions
see that's why i'm surprised that he
said uh you know just plain old smooth
peanut butter i i thought the oil
would actually serve as sort of a
natural lubricant
yeah but
but the crunchy peanut butter scratches
and this is not true oh
ribbed for his pleasure you know yeah
dan you just got schooled
[Laughter]
well this is why we're doing this
to educate the public
yeah
so okay
so when you say i just opened an
untainted jar of peanut butter what do
you what is a tainted jar versus
untainted jar
a tanner jar is a jar that's had my dick
in it
[Laughter]
them or do you put them in different
spots in the kitchen they've got only
different spots yeah
and do you do you have a guest over
they don't see the peanut butter okay
yeah it's in a secret spot okay
and um do you reuse the tainted jars
like how many times do you reuse them
before they go bad
every now and then yeah if i'm trying to
use the fresh dry every time oh you know
and then is that that's not a very
precise
measurement that's peanut butter's
expensive you can't buy a new jar every
time yeah yeah yeah
that's a good point
especially with the way inflation is
right now
yeah that's true that's so true man it
sucks man you know craig used to be able
to get a jar a week and now when it's
down to a jar every two weeks nobody can
uh exactly nobody can compete with that
crack has also listed some of these jars
on ebay is that is that correct craig
yes i did i i used jar i listed on you
i had a million billion dollars but
somebody bought it but they never paid
sons of [ __ ]
you said you had my hopes up you had a
500
bed on a tainted jar
does the tainted peanut butter jar have
your dna in it if you know what i mean
or no
well yeah but it's probably dried out by
the time it gets to the top holy [ __ ]
bro that's a certain type of jelly one
might say
[Music]
it's a sticky situation
oh my goodness
hey you know what i just thought of we
need to introduce who is the guy that we
had on that
artist in fleshlights yeah yeah we need
to get connect him with craig to make
like a peanut butter themed flesh i know
who we're talking about right he's
really popular on tick tock he's like
yes i know yourself yeah yeah
would you be interested in collabing
with him on like a peanut butter
flashlight yeah
here's a nice sticky one to light up the
runway
some people don't like the crunch but i
love it
there's another conflict we need to talk
to you about is um
white cloth gabe he's he's he said that
fridays is for white clubs
now
you're saying that fridays is for peanut
butter i'm seeing a potential conflict
there are you open to moving the peanut
butter to a different day of the week
are you not budging on that
did we lose him is he gone
oh
he dropped out
did we do we go too far straight what
did the light craig is guys
this is so unexpected make sure to
follow him he's awesome and chill love
for
formerly known as craig oh wait he just
popped
his internet must have cut out or
something it's important we get this
quest last question yeah hey craig sorry
we we lost you there
he's reconnecting his audio yeah no
worries
no worries somebody called oh somebody
called
oh oops
was that was it the was it the jiffy
people
not yet but i'm hoping to get a
sponsorship i think
yeah
um i was asking you that we have you
know there's a member another
person
that we speak with the good guy
white club
yeah and he's he's pronounced friday's
is for white claws now you've said that
peanut butter is for fridays or would
you be willing to move that to a
different day of the week or you is
there no budging on friday no budget
wow
really
yeah
so this is actually i prefer monster to
be honest
you prefer monster than white cloth yeah
yeah if he was the green monster guy
then i might budge but
not white fall no he's not moving
so this is okay so we kind of had a
impasse here oh we might have to well
i'm gonna have to i don't think gabe can
move it because friday's like his whole
thing
right i i can make an exception every
now and then
so you're saying maybe every other
every other
third
week of the month we can move yeah i'm
willing to compromise yeah okay that's
good you're a good guy okay
and um well okay i'm we're wondering if
maybe setting up a conversation between
you guys maybe seeing if you can work it
out
yeah we could that that'd be something
pretty fun yeah okay battle for the
friday night spot
okay
okay okay
craig you're such a treat um do you
stick your dick in anything else you
want to talk about or is that it
like cherries
cherries
yeah what does that mean what
how
how's that work
never mind
[Laughter]
you mean like a cherry pie or like a
cherry like the fruit cherries
a woman's chair
oh woman's sherry okay well that's i've
never heard i've never actually heard a
vagina referred to as a cherry before
well now yeah i'm used to the guidelines
oh
he's speaking in tik-tok maybe he could
say taco or something
[Laughter]
is just confusing
you could say cherry pie american pie
there you go
i wonder if we could if we could suggest
some other hot kind of household items
that might be
that you could try putting your dick in
and then compare it to how
the peanut butter is and you can braid
it for us like maybe in a future segment
i'm open to ideas yes
like i'd say yeah jelly cameron jelly is
a natural complement to the peanut
butter uh mayonnaise mayonnaise would be
fantastic well i did a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich one friday oh you did oh
yeah untainted or tainted
well it was tainted by the time i got
done
[Laughter]
yeah this would be good so what's that
we got to work on some some
some formats but but craig what a
treasure what a treat to talk to you
so such a fun time thanks for calling
formerly known as craig
on tick tock anywhere else people should
uh should
check you out
yeah come follow me
just on tick tock or anywhere else i'm
just on tick tock okay tick tock
formerly known as craig fortnight god
also walking forward are you good at
fortnight craig
i'm okay i get lucky a lot
yeah
nah i admit it i get beat by like 10
year old every now and then
i tell you what those 10 year olds have
an advantage over
us older guys our reflexes just ain't
what it exactly you know it's just not
fair
that's all they do too is fortnite
fortnite yeah
i got peanut butter i got
thanks for everything what a great call
thanks buddy thanks greg
bye
wow that was that was incredible
[Music]
wow yeah well we uh got to the bottom of
it yeah
i wasn't sure if he was going to be more
cagey about it but he just came right
out
let us know he just came right out and
said it jerry
he i mean he's pretty well endowed you
know dude that's a fatty bro yeah and i
wonder if it gets his balls too you know
like you know right up in there mm-hmm
crunchy well we couldn't there's always
time for more questions
i really thought when you guys showed me
that
that it's probably not the case
yeah i thought it was kidding as well
well you know what's even more
impressive about that
there's a little space at the top yeah
so that's adding an extra
right quarter of an inch or or half an
inch
at the top yeah because it doesn't go
right up to the top
yeah that's true man's got a choke
shot out shout out
what a great
i love his like so what is a tainted jar
oh it's when i put my dick in
oh yeah right okay hi i'm dick chip
zach are you satisfied with that
we got our answer we got our answers
zach was the guy zach's a big fan of of
craig's and uh he wanted us to get to
the bottom of the did zach think that it
was
what he was doing or it wasn't oh i knew
he was i could make it
a funny guy though this all came up
because he showed up on my feed yeah
that's what happened and i was like you
guys have to see this and i showed it to
zach and he's like oh yeah i love this
guy
oh look at his description on tick tock
today i will be on the h3 podcast oh
he's sending his audience over thank you
so much
welcome to the new
yeah
check out his links
uh
what links do you have maybe not live
amazon wishlist i want to see what's on
his wishlist
this is always interesting
underwear
monsters
he loves monster energy he posted it i
like monster too i'm just afraid to
drink it regularly his car is like full
of empty cans
jiffy peanut butter yeah glasses reading
glasses jiffy peanut butter knees not a
cardboard car battery only needs one
uh ankle socks
well sure skittles
more monster more monster
reeses
[Music]
so that's that's a modest list yeah i
wonder he's got some jog that's awesome
some underwear
or some jiffy
i mean i feel like the car battery is
the most crucial ones let's get us at
the carpet
that's true
that's a great point maybe it's for like
ball and [ __ ] torture
very impossible
all combined make something really
[ __ ] up
well because if he needs a car battery
he wouldn't put it here he would just
buy it but maybe there's like [ __ ] and
ball torture where he zaps
his
his vents
should we buy him the battery dan you
want to process that sure i can buy that
for him
yeah let's get him the the mighty
max battery maybe throw in the enclosed
socks for pride mobility oh it's a
mobility scooter battery i was going to
guess that because i think he is uh in a
mobility uh well there you go it's uh
people helping people here
yeah bro let's get you [ __ ] back on
that thing man
we should ask maybe ask him before he's
like oh i don't actually need that what
is that well he's got it on the ball
what is this
if he doesn't need it let's get him the
battery yeah
we're in the battery and you know what
i'm getting them uh a thing of jiff a
jiff yeah i'm getting a jar jiff how
could i not and the battery for the
mobility yeah this is a shout out to uh
dan
and don't ever say i'm not generous
when i'm buying craig a jar of yo seven
bucks dan what the [ __ ] nah just the
battery
[Laughter]
that's actually
surprising though peanut butter is
exciting oh it's a pack of three things
oh it's a three pack that makes sense
yeah
oh so so even more generous than i
expected three pack of gif
and a
mobility
battery so thank you to craig what a
great call
[Music]
shout out i love looking at people's
wish list
it's it's always the best it's so nice
it's always i love it if you guys find
anyone else's wish list i love looking
at it it's my favorite
what exactly do you do
to the peanut butter on peanut butter
friday
i have no idea what that is so let's
just close that
there you go okay let's finally
oh wait this is an important update so
we've talked a lot about jimmy lee on
the last episode yes and about how he
was obsessively trying to get on jimbo
kimball jimmy kimmel
and dude this was on the show this is
[ __ ] amazing so amazing you guys
zach did you know that they were
recording when you guys were walking by
we saw that they were setting up for
some type of outdoor like
roving reporter type [ __ ] but it wasn't
when we were there whether we're filming
oh this was just him yeah at this point
we left i mean so so this means that he
kept walking by there first all day we
we left around 4 30 i think he was
shooting until about i don't know eight
or nine
so he's just walking back and forth with
the kimmel [ __ ] oh yeah so he definitely
knew they were recording oh yeah he was
very adamant he was like we got to be a
kimmel at three hurry up
so here it is i mean
this is amazing yeah
this is [ __ ] phenomenal um why did
reagan say she's named after her mom
aisha um i believe
and you can see his security beeline
towards him because this was like
probably the third time they told us to
oh
let's watch again
why did reagan say she's named after her
mom aisha um i believe
oh yeah
wait wait what did you say cam
you can you can see jimmy's kimmel's
security team be lined towards him
because they they they got very oh that
was jimmy's security team
and uh yeah kimmel's security is the guy
they're the ones that actually look like
security guards
this one looks like an agent from the
matrix that's the guy i [ __ ] with he's
crazy and then here's an actual security
guard
so they told us we
we walked back and forth and they told
us to get the [ __ ] out what was like two
or three times yeah yeah but apparently
he just kept doing it but to be fair to
jimmy that's public property they don't
control who walks so they try to pin us
like say saying that we were stopping
traffic well yeah we weren't
you know what
those guys think that they've got money
and power and they can control who walks
on there and i think jimmy needs to
teach him a [ __ ] lesson bro all right
that's [ __ ] they don't own the
sidewalk [ __ ] them
so power to jimmy
yeah good for jimmy for getting on that
show in fact if i had it my way i'd have
a move down to hollywood and show up
there every goddamn day and walk back
and forth non-stop oh yeah he was so
adamant that we were going to make it on
that trip he did he was so just like
we're on man so wait have you talked to
him since this clip he sent me an email
today
um which i sent our chat i don't know if
you want me to read it no not that one
was there one about jimmy kimmel i when
i sent it to him he he's like wow wow
wow it's happening kid and then he's
like
can you help me download this and then
like a minute went by
he's like can you help me download this
is there any way to download this so i
just sent him a screenshot
and he's like wow can you help me
download this
well somebody download the clip and well
i sent it to him but he didn't
understand that it was a video yeah the
screen recorded but yeah
well he's gonna make it
as long as it doesn't record download it
doesn't as long as it doesn't involve
downloading anything he's definitely
going to make it oh yeah i'm eating
peanut butter now oh my god peanut
butter friday baby
update um despite being on his wish list
uh amazon will not let you send a car
battery as a as a creative for some
reason yeah it's like probably dangerous
i guess so i'm just giving him a bunch
of monster and some extra peanut butter
and
i'm just piling on a few of the other
items tell me all right we tried to get
the battery pull up the car
i'm logged in it's got my address
popping up all over the place but if he
actually needs that battery i want to
get it for him like maybe we could send
him money for it
uh he does have
absolutely just give him should we just
send him money instead of buying all
this crap on amazon maybe or amazon give
chris let's talk about aftershocks yeah
we'll do it either way let's talk about
him that battery
we need to get him out and about yeah
jimmy also met noah beck while in l.a
they did a collab
he even got him to do the pose
check it out awkward noah beck loves the
jersey outlaw oh at boa steakhouse
i bet the paparazzi were there waiting
for jimmy oh yeah
steakhouse is i guess one of those
beverly hills places where the paparazzi
hangs out right mm-hmm
probably
flipped
he really got him to do this hand thing
huh i don't know how but jimmy's got a
way with words man well he's just so um
he's so persistent it's hard to say no
to him
he'd be like do me a favor do the hands
thing like this hands up hands up hands
up come on just do the hand thing hands
up i think we did like a hands take at
least what like 30 times
really yeah he kept like hitting me with
like so jersey outlaw
here in hollywood
with zach
and it was just like did you guys get
that on film yeah
i can't wait to see this is gonna be the
best
[ __ ] video
cam have you started editing this thing
yeah yeah it's giving me a migraine but
i'm working on it
oh man i gotta say like so many of his
jokes aren't gonna make the final cut
sorry jimmy but
it's too hot for tv 60 of them
is it really too hot for tv
like just race it just straight up like
racist stuff oh yeah i was hiding my
face behind the camera the whole time i
couldn't my god that's the people he was
talking about
is there a way to just bleep stuff to
make it usable
um i'll show you i'll show you where
it's at after the show yeah it was rough
yeah i trust your intuition though
that's unbelievable man i don't know how
i dealt with that all day i mean i had
the support of ian cam and love
but it was bad dude
it was
like god loved jimmy but it was like
getting to a point where i was [ __ ]
pissed
and zack is very good in crowds like
zach has done shows where he's very calm
in control of everyone and handles it
very well and throughout the day you can
just see zach start to lose
demeanor all right well well
congratulations to
the jersey outlaw it's happening in his
words it's happening
one more time
jimmy lee on jimmy kimmel he did it he
made it there he is
and jimmy's just security escorting him
we're on kimmel
we did it on hollywood boulevard we did
it live
wait for the press releases about jimmy
jimmy the jersey outlaw on jimmy
kimmel's show when we when we were
shooting is very adamant on us showing
his magazine that we promoted like a
year ago from hollywood well the
hollywood reporters yeah like that yeah
he was very adamant he's like start it
with this started with this
god love him though
the outlaw baby
um
we've also got an update from fiddlehead
coffee the fan who called in last week
or no last episode with a brain tumor
he said he's gotten a bunch of orders he
said quote i woke up this morning having
raised enough funds to provide a week of
meals to over 800 refugee families and
counting for a month of meals
for 200 families
sorry i was muted um
i just saw that i actually have an email
from him from just two hours ago
with a further update it's actually up
to 1500 families with a week meals
medical character and assistance
fiddlehead coffee guys
love that man and i'm glad that he's
selling some coffee
so can i show this photo you're being so
cagey about it
maybe boxing in i mean it's just a photo
what am i supposed to do what do you
what do you want to tell me about this
photo i'll explain it to you
as i did right before the show
uh we were going to announce everything
today i'm sorry guys i know you keep
asking but it's been delayed again we
have to delay the announcement there's a
lot that goes into it into this a lot of
lawyers a lot of so that's fine but what
am i taking from this photo
so the joke was this is the big
announcement and it's supposed to be
what's the announcement
this is the announcement this is the
joke this was the update what's the
announcement that me and i dub sparred
oh
who won
items is really tough
okay i wasn't don't say anything but did
he [ __ ] you up
no he was he was definitely
taking it easy on me in the beginning
and then like towards because like at
first like his coach was saying you know
no head shots let's just you know keep
it loose and then towards the end i was
like holy [ __ ] bounce me [ __ ] he [ __ ]
you up
but this was a while ago you're probably
better now he's much taller though
i can't wait i think people are gonna
get annihilated you're going to win but
some people are going to get annihilated
bro
so there you go okay exciting
announcement apparently a b sparred
thank you i think you kind of took the
luster out of it a little bit there's no
laundry i mean that was the joke there
is no luster we don't i mean now it's
layers of no luster it's lust
it's not even like
it's not even like guild it's matte it's
just matte black
totally
um
ela did you see that i'm people are
using me
what i said about exercising in a
alpha
sigma grind set vid i love it pick it up
life's too short to exercise i'm just
gonna be honest there's so many better
things to do than exercise it is a shame
for a man to grow old without seeing the
beauty and strength of which his body is
capable
you know what else socrates dead [ __ ]
kids i knew that was coming
you know what i mean i'm just saying if
you're going to quote the man
it is a shame for a man to grow and not
see what is
his body is capable and also it's a [ __ ]
and also [ __ ] children
i'm just saying bro
you doing that
just saying
just saying yeah bro get it
[ __ ] yeah then
wow
did that video get a lot of views life's
too i want to see the original
i want to see all the comments about
ethan fat
uh top comment is uh socrates is dead so
that didn't work out
good
i'm still alive
here let me read another comment this
guy put his heart and soul into this one
one thing i find funny about these fit
bros who have shamed ethan for calling
joe unhealthy because he himself is fat
is their definition of healthy is always
jacked yeah that's a good point jack is
not healthy like okay you're fit but
you're also putting your body through a
lot
yeah even arnold schwarzenegger was like
being this big is very unhealthy people
who bodybuild like this they don't live
long their hearts literally [ __ ]
explode in their body you're giving them
yo he got a lot of likes yeah how many
views did this get uh
a hundred and or eight hundred actually
okay and and what's there it is seven
hundred thousand
and that that was like the standout
video too his other videos have like
three thousand views yeah so let's read
the comments this is awesome
wait go to the top comment
want to call out content creators who
have legit stolen my edit bro what the
[ __ ] you talking about use my clip
don't worry about that i think you may
have stolen this from someone else
who got significantly less views
so it's layers of so go to the top
negativity bro you said why would
someone say something like this
so exercising one of the most fun dude
bro i'm kidding don't you hear people
laughing you [ __ ] idiots
he's negative bro he likes to belittle
others for exercising since he has given
up on training on multiple occasions
i've never
it
why
why ethan's such a ill now
life is short if you don't exercise okay
genius that was a lot it's actually live
is too wrong too short right
yeah i was given a benefit up there
wait wait so many better things to do
does none of them excuse me i beat elden
ring last night so what the [ __ ] right
did you beat it yeah it's done thank god
nightmare is over
watch anime for one which is where
you're showing baki
like sitting around watching netflix and
eating doritos yeah i consider that
better who are you to judge my [ __ ]
use of time ol
if that is your real name
anyway
this is great this is like my dream
this is my dream bro
listen fat
this is so fun fat ugly and stupid
they say uh
anyway whatever yeah
it's great to exercise i'm just gonna be
honest there's so many better things to
do than exercise it is a shame for a man
to grow it is a shame for a man not to
take a boy as a
lover seeing the beauty and strength of
which his body is capable
[Music]
hit the [ __ ] jab spend five hours at
the gym every day exercise three times a
day [ __ ] suck dudes dicks cause semen
increases testosterone
eat that is so true
this could be us ethan but you playing
bro
[ __ ] yeah yeah
put pictures of jack dudes on your wall
um
you know what's better use of time
putting your dick in peanut butter
[Laughter]
amen to that dude
love it
machine gun kelly has more cringe out
this guy is just never stuck by the way
this is so
he's i realized
31 years old
okay which makes this whole conversation
about him not being a real emo
even more cringe
i think the emo credentials get
revoked at like what 25 at tops
tops that's being generous 18 yeah i
mean yeah
19 you know
i think emo's cringe past 19 but here's
a 31 year old
oh my god guys why didn't you tell me
there was a group of emo guardians on
social media declaring what's emo or not
that i didn't make the cut emo emo emo
emo emo emo emo emo emo emo emo
yo that man
i don't know oh
he's 31 dude i didn't know that i
thought he was like 25 or something
i learned from j station when someone
starts a video with oh my god guys
i'm gonna see some cringe
well i wonder what the comments are like
on his tick tock oh what is this bro how
did you ever get megan fox
don't you feel silly
who hurt him
nurse he's out again bro you good well
you're really going through some [ __ ] eh
damn eminem did him dirty people it's
funny people go why am i now
he made a diss track on eminem oh
okay and then eminem made a diss track
on him
did he destroy him i never really
followed that did m just destroy him
massacred him but i'm biased he had to
change genres of music that's what
that's the joke is he had he had to
become an emo kid didn't he mgk like
didn't mgk hit on eminem's like young
daughter or something yeah
well that's not the first time he's hit
on young girls right yeah
is that
before or after the diss track
i think it was because before and that's
what led to it
yeah so he's hitting on eminem's
daughter and then eminem was pissed or
yeah
i wasn't brought up on it now
[Music]
yo 17 dog what is that
you seen that clip he's like 17 dog what
are you talking about kendall jenner
yeah yeah i don't know it's like we're
both famous age is different listen
we're high heels
damn it i've said that so many
[ __ ] times i hope that
i'm snagging that don't let me move to
la oof
[Music]
until
she's 18.
i'm not waiting till she's 18 i'll go
now
i'm 23 dog like
i'm not like a creepy age like you know
what i'm saying i'm 23 bro she's 17 and
she's like a celebrity like there's no
there is no limits right there robert
plant who was one of the greatest league
singers ever for all y'all don't know
your song for led zeppelin dated a girl
that was 14. axel rose who was one of
the biggest badasses ever dated a girl
that was 16 and wrote a song on his
first album about the girl that was 16.
i don't care say what you want man if
kendall jenner is in your bedroom naked
and you're 50 you're going
what cool oh my god yeah so how old was
eminem's uh daughter at the time
you got intel on that um
16 says cam he was hitting on a 16 year
old girl
yeah well i mean it's par for the course
what
he's like yo
yo dad chill
shin gun kelly then 20 20.
did you guys 10 22 tweeted that eminem's
16 year old daughter
hallie is hot as [ __ ]
wow
we're actually 16. okay so i just saw a
picture of eminem's daughter and i have
to say she's hot as [ __ ] the most
respectful way possible because m is
king
and then six years later eminem dropped
the diss track
response well it was a line in a song
and then
mgk made a diss track in response oh
yeah no no mj key machine gun kelly made
a distraction after eminem mentioned him
in a song
can you get i'm curious can you give me
the history i want to go through this
now
yeah okay so
what was that it was just almost what
kamikaze is kamikaze and there's a lyric
where he goes i'm talking to you but you
already know who the f you are kelly i
don't use subliminals don't sneak diss
me but keep commenting on my daughter
haley
but i'm sure it sounded better than i
just
that wasn't even that bad
yeah it wasn't then like mgk responded
with a diss track that talked about m's
age and about his sobriety and a bunch
of other rap it was called rap devil
right yeah how desperate like he barely
mentions you not that bad and you're
like i'm going in against this dinosaur
and then eminem puts out a song called
kill shot and it was literally the kill
shot yeah but then mgk became and then
he became emo
and he turned into this
girl
yo eminem put out a diss track and this
is what happened
so when was eminem's this drug that's
something like like two years ago i
think it was 20 2018 and it was like
yeah
so is it was that really that powerful
of a hit it was
really it [ __ ] him up dude
man
i think
you know
mgk has a lot of haters already so
people were
very willing to see him get destroyed
you know
damn machine gun kelly reaped though he
got 4 350 million from his i gotta say
that song is not bad it's not bad how
dare you rap devil
compared to the [ __ ] he's doing now
you know i my theory is that around the
same time he was shooting that movie the
dirt where he plays uh tommy lee
and i think he just liked the rockstar
character too much and then just after
that started making a bunch of rock
songs and
change genres i think tommy lee would
rather kill himself than write that kind
of music i mean that guy was a rock and
roller
you know what i mean
he's also teaming up with like travis
barker and all his music i don't know
anything about
machine gun i thought he was a rapper
and now he's trying to make some dog
[ __ ] you sound like a bee
doing like
midge
mid-aughts emo revival [ __ ] which yeah
i've
with the ancients
tick tockers and somebody who was a
teenager in that era i i am not
i'm not excited about this emo thing
coming back this is i'm in love with
i don't think it's going it should have
stayed in the past
i don't think it's coming back if this
is the face of emo rock it's not
happening
i got to go back and listen to this song
now that i'm in more into the mgk lore
you know yeah it's a bop dude
it's a bomb
cool
fun
fun good times just saying
um
what the [ __ ] was this
i don't know if this guy's a comedian or
if he's genuinely unhinged lunatic
this is put man addresses uh
uh you know he's a comedian he's a
comedian
quote unquote yeah
very um he's like a anti-vaxx dude and
he's an anti-vaxx comedian
uh or troll or whatever you wanna call
it he's just
okay so he addresses city council
and makes a rap about solenski and putin
so here we go mgk eminem look out feast
your eyes baby
when i'm in the booth spitting on the
mic
[Music]
putin hates all of them blacks putin is
a bad racist what the [ __ ] you say
i gotta bring it back on that
now when you get your time slot this
week in front of the city council you
could do anything you want basically say
whatever you want
it's pretty good pretty pretty abusable
putin hates all of them
putin hates all them blacks
yeah that's what he said nice
that's pretty wild statement
is a bad racist
put them in the ground white or brown
and i'm in plain old town and you know
you just got found i'm a pimp on a blimp
unless
[Music]
this is tough man
this is really tough
does this guy have an act like a show he
takes on the road
no he's more just like an internet troll
from what i could tell like i said i
mean he he does all these sort of uh
satirical uh
performance art things this isn't the
first time he's gone into city council
meetings doing this as well
[Music]
ukraine and i go insane put a bullet in
putin's brain
you know that is the plan
i'm a zelinski stan so is he pro putin
or something
maybe it's i i was looking at his stuff
this morning
and it's kind of hard to tell because
again everything he does is like
satirical so like he had these he had
another rap where he was rapping about
how everybody should get vaccinated and
i was like oh okay so maybe he isn't
like an anti-vaxx guy but then i
realized he was like
there's several layers of irony going on
he's like an anti-anti-vaxxer
essentially
he has a face like a hog yeah he's he
he's he's a hog he's got a charlie kerr
yes he's got the charlie and rick
syndrome for sure i love you vladimir
zelinski you are so smart what's the
smell did somebody fire
no way what can you say
you think you'd spend more time writing
that like
he knew when his time slot was he could
have he could have done a lot more prep
i mean you gonna come out with pimp on a
blimp
we're definitely a political superior
country yeah yeah that's true
i mean hey
it's democracy
you know democracy in action
you say you want more people involved in
our democracy right and then you say you
don't want this make up your mind sheep
this is high-level discourse this is
what freedom of speech looks like
okay before we move on
to the main stories
tim poole really
uh made such a bizarre tweet today and
you know temple hates me
he's a he's a total grifter everybody
knows tim paul i'm assuming
did you see these ela
right before i was getting ready to come
to work i saw this
this is not a joke this is totally
sincere
he says i went to dinner with my
girlfriend and was told it was a 20
minute wait
after only a few minutes a couple walked
in and was seated right away
i complained and left right away i don't
tolerate [ __ ] and i don't tolerate
people that i should
who think i should care when they
who think i should care when they do
what what a badass he continues i worked
for a major corporate news outlet and
was paid hundreds of thousands of
dollars when they told me to get woke i
said no and i tried to break my contract
i don't tolerate [ __ ] if you do by
all means do you but don't come to my
sad because you won't stand up for
yourself what is that don't worry i'm
talking about there's
there's so much to unpack yeah there's
so much
wait i mean like okay well is there just
one more i guess yeah there's more he
says i agree i'm often arrogant and
condescending i'm a disagreeable person
overconfident and i troll people on
twitter for fun
but as they say
well-behaved women seldom make history
what
which really puts a twist on that one
is he gonna say that this is trolling
for fun
all right
like but the whole situation
that he got upset over it's like okay
you don't even know what's the story
that happens all the time exactly maybe
they had a reservation exactly it's like
welcome to the world and also just maybe
just chill dude like i was like is he on
drugs so he thinks the person owns like
on purpose didn't let him sit because
they know tim paul
i i think he just doesn't tolerate
[ __ ]
he's in line there's no acceptable
reason those people could be seated
before him i mean i don't know it
doesn't matter if they were here before
it doesn't matter that reservation it
doesn't matter if it's their [ __ ]
dying wish and he has 10 minutes left to
live and all he wants is a goddamn
[ __ ] matching ball soup
he doesn't tolerate [ __ ] yeah so he
literally is a karen
the guy went and he's bragging about
being a carrot i i mean as somebody who
hosted for like the first you know nine
months or a year that i worked at a
restaurant like i know exactly this
person and they are the [ __ ] worst
like the [ __ ] like um excuse me why
did they get sick before me yeah people
yeah yeah it's just
god that gives me [ __ ] flashbacks so
entitled that and delete how do you get
upset over that it's like that literally
happens almost every single time i go to
a restaurant there's always something
there's lots of ends lots of outs bag of
turtles you know flaming turkey yeah
they could have just walked in from
outside for all you knows
like they were waiting outside right
exactly
or they were meeting someone inside or
that yeah also he literally says he only
waited a few minutes
like he wasn't even there waiting long
and he's
he's auditing the the
the hostess the whole time he says he
was there with his girlfriend uh was he
like trying to like show how alpha he
was like by probably making a scene and
storming out it's very alpha
to throw attention maybe next time make
a reservation
and i'm gonna get pissed off about it
dude this this van is not well this this
this is mentally this is mental illness
what trying to unpack the last the last
yeah what is the last first tweet is
like really a brilliant this one yeah i
mean there's a few that are like really
confusing but that one i don't tolerate
[ __ ] and i don't tolerate people who
think
i should care when they
do when they
tolerate [ __ ] and i yeah or like oh
i thought it was more like
when they think i should care when they
care why should i care about things you
care about yeah but that doesn't really
matter what does that mean in context
yeah that i don't think in context that
really makes sense
[ __ ] and i don't it was giving me
demi lovato yogurt vibes oh yeah yeah oh
yeah i waited two minutes and i and it
ruined my whole day
i mean the real [ __ ] here is this
tweet
i had to double take it because i was
just in disbelief i mean how can you
tweet this out first of all i was like
okay he mentioned his girlfriend for no
reason like obviously he's just trying
to do something about with that because
one of his most famous lines is like oh
he's
the single guy right yeah okay and it's
definitely not my problem in the world
everybody else yeah
temple is such a loser i can't
believe
that
he's like the best loser
the state of right of conservative
politics on youtube
these people are all just so sad and
[ __ ] like so bad actually beta like
insecure unhinged lunatics they have no
comfort in their own skin and their
sexuality and their gender it's like
it's like how do you live you are in
such turmoil at all times bro
ultimately
they're just so upset at being who they
are
look at what he tweeted a short time
what was the last sentence about women
though seems to be
him maybe trying
yeah
he trolled like he was trolling but it's
just like what that's not really
how that works yeah i see i saw this as
well i'm pretty sure that same try and
be like ha ha i'm laughing i'm laughing
with you guys and not at me
oh he's actually trending on the right
he says i love this website app what is
twitter now anyway lol anyway thank you
for following me
no bro what
are you saying why are you even saying
this part it's just like
either he's on drugs or
i think he's just really [ __ ] dumb
dude he says uh
man
oh and then my favorite is he goes
you know what they say well-behaved
women seldom make me yeah what is this
yeah i'm pretty sure
that doesn't have okay let's break that
down that doesn't refer to being a dick
to a hostess that's not what they mean
by well-being right okay
second of all and third it's about you
know women
most likely
you're not
this is a [ __ ] psychotic [ __ ]
it's so weird also i troll we do a
little trolling i troll people on
twitter for fun
we do a little uh trolling you've heard
him talk on the show he has no sense of
humor yeah not at all play he goes ethan
is ruined cleveland
is ruining everything this whole shtick
is just getting mad and
i mean he's just like kind of like a
little tucker carlson
is is damaging everything making it all
worse
making it always he
if you listen to his show he has no
sense of humor the man is incapable of
humanism
wait he said that about me
i think it was actually about sam cedar
cedar is a lying coward
okay
it's like he's so upfront i might not be
right about that one who's you you call
it yeah who is he calling comment do you
remember you know flaming turd bag
okay
that's not what we asked for no
you know somehow this is more bizarre
than the dude [ __ ] peanut butter of
all the things we talked about today
these these meats are
definitely the most wine yeah i mean
make [ __ ] peanut butter at least you
know on it makes sense in a way like
forget it
this is awesome it was funny you know
he was very funny
that's the top response
these guys are so pathetic and they're
so successful it's just awesome
being a ring grifter's the easiest job
in the world you guys you know i was
kind of wondering maybe they didn't see
him because he want to take his head off
you know some classy restaurants don't
you wear a hat it's a name from a diner
oh yeah it did
he said i went to a diner with my
girlfriend oh i thought it went to
dinner
and by the way when you go to a diner
wait so what's the what's the issue
exactly if you go to a diner and there's
a 20 minute wait that means it's busy as
you walk there's all kinds of [ __ ] going
on tons of people waiting lots of people
going in and out
it's it's this is
you are you are bad you are just a bad
human being you're just a menace society
a literal karen
well he's a misbehaved woman actually
[Laughter]
and he's trying to make history by
demanding he get seated
okay i complained and i left
i left because i don't tolerate [ __ ]
my girlfriend was super uh was super
impressed she
she loved that
oh we got our astrology girl
uh i can get it set up let me uh shoot
the link over here god we're not going
to talk about any of the topics again i
do want to talk about kim yeah we have
to talk about that we'll get to it we'll
get to it after this
we need to order food then
mexican
i've been mexican in a minute hey
let's go gila
sure that spicy [ __ ] up food truck or
you don't like that right love that
doesn't sound the food truck food
that place is kind of [ __ ] they make
all their food way too spicy i had some
taco like uh street corner tacos and
that was one of the best thing i've ever
had downtown l.a yeah the street taco no
it was a little bit outside of downtown
but
i yeah i see them everywhere and so good
well this particular one i think you had
it before you didn't like it
yeah i'm excited and they always forget
somebody's food for some reason we've
never gotten a complete order ever from
them oh really we they always yeah
that's how you know it's legit
yeah i dude wanting in and out
oh internet could be fun
a little more in and out
of the internet you don't like it right
now
uh yeah but whatever
i'm gonna live
the wait he's gotta outline out he's
visiting california i mean it's like one
of the things yeah what do you mean some
in and out
hey a little bit of interlining wait do
they even do delivery we'd have to send
someone
oh okay well
i think they might be on posties no
no
they don't [ __ ] with that well
then whatever i mean i'll have some
tacos it is good though
let me ask you though hilo will tie
break for us okay sure
so we've got to talk about um
skeet
and kanye
yeah i'm i'm getting
but before that
oh we're going to talk to our astrologer
we've provided her with our birthdays
birth signs
birth time
and uh we provide all to
uh marin altman
and she is gonna call in and tell us
about our personality
based on the information
and i mean if you wanted to just discuss
this uh whole thing here she is here's
her let's let's see what kind of
companies represent world events that
catalyze long lasting changes in one
area of your life i will repeat that
again eclipses represent world events
that catalyze long-lasting change in one
area of your life they symbolize world
events that take you for a ride it's not
generally you doing something unless
you're big enough of a world leader to
literally literally cause a world event
yeah
here's another this is a popular let's
see
pray for the fixed signs this spring as
in tourist scorpio aquarius and leo but
mostly taurus and scorpio nothing's
wrong with them they're just about to
undergo eclipse season
okay what did you say
i have to listen to that again
pray for the fixed signs this spring as
in taurus scorpio aquarius and leo but
mostly taurus and scorpio nothing's
wrong with them they're just about to
undergo eclipse season what is that what
did she say could someone just translate
that for me
the top comment is what does that mean
uh all i heard was my sign and that i'm
about to go through eclipse season and
she did not look happy about it
i've heard about i remember when a few
years ago the all the rave was retro or
mercury in retrograde that's still all
the rage everybody's always talking
about retrograde how could mercury have
such an effect on us
and why is it so often in retrograde
right how could it always been right
yeah yeah what is it it seems like a
rare thing
someone said i'm tired of being the main
character
scorpios are tired
we need a rest damn scorpios are getting
slaughtered with all the retroglades and
eclipses scorpios have a tough dude
they do
or so i hear
um she's uh in the waiting room all
right so this is uh
marin altman very excited
this spring as in tourist school
she gives me she gives me um
scorpio i'm getting the
it's not the vibe hey um marin nice to
meet you am i saying your name right
sorry it's playing your clothes back to
you yeah it's like karen within him nice
to meet you as well karen what the heck
marin nice uh nice to meet you thank you
for calling in it's a pleasure to have
you
it's interesting the setup there we can
see all the the details of your camera i
literally can't get it off i forgot i
brought it in yeah it's there's
something wrong with it i constantly
have to stream with randomly it looks
like i know you stream with those yeah
there's no way to remove the histogram
totally so i've done my best i've never
seen that before i i've seen it you are
using an elgato cam link
uh
is that why is it the key yeah it's the
camera guy had that problem too yeah you
have to
i can i can help you after the show oh
look amy is going to fix that
i never thought it was the cam link i
always thought it was the sony so i
brought it in
yeah it's the sony with the cam link
there's some problems them together
you see you see you you trade your
knowledge of the stars and we trade our
technical knowledge we'll do an exchange
of knowledge here that's what we do yes
very valuable
all right well when did you get into
astrology
so something i found really early when i
started to read my parents gave me
newspapers as a toddler and next to the
cartoons or the horoscopes and i've
never really been a picture kind of
person so immediately i saw that and was
interested in them um the weird girl at
parties growing up that was always
giving people like readings and when i
got into high school i started tracking
world events more than people's
personalities um grew up doing acting
but then when i got to nyu i transferred
into philosophy and started tracking
like political cycles and more
large-scale world events with astrology
and then as i was graduating two years
ago i found uh finance and crypto and
started doing mostly financial markets
and tracking that with astrology so
then i guess you could stay nearly
lifelong but did not find my focus in it
until i was becoming an adult
so you use astrology to track crypto
changes
yeah so with astrology we're seeing
planetary cycles and you can correspond
those to world events and see if there's
a correlation that feels or that appears
valid to you it was extremely valid and
convincing to me in the fact that
there's repetition that happens that can
be tracked using world uh planetary
cycles and world events so i was very
interested in crypto like inherently um
finance is very interesting to me as
well and so finding crypto being um
like with a philosophy background the
ethical side of um the ethical side of
the harm that many central banking
systems do to like their citizens led me
to crypto firstly for ethics but then i
actually found a big interest in the
logistics of finance in general um so
tracking those world events appeals to
me more and combining the two is not i'm
not the first person to do that i'm in
no way like unique necessarily in it but
it was combining two major interests of
mine in a way that felt very fulfilling
so how is your crypto portfolio doing as
a
do you feel like you're cheating a
little bit if the stars are telling you
what to do you don't have to follow the
charts or anything
i mean you have to follow the charts to
execute your trades so
any astrologer who's used to tracking
aspects which is like a basic concept
can tell you like oh this looks good or
bad but you have to be into technical
analysis to execute actually so so how's
your portfolio
right now it's mostly stable coins
because like there's so much shakiness
in the market that i'm not really
entering any large but overall are you
way up
since the beginning yes but then i
brought a property so
congratulations
the stars have delivered
literally yeah okay so so do you have
credentials is there some kind of
credentials you get in astrology or are
you just someone who studied it
a lot
you can get technically credentials
through multiple organizations but
i didn't feel the need to go through any
of those mostly because my rise into
being well known was so fast and so
quick as a young person that i let my um
i have a background in like philosophy
from nyu and then i was in a graduate
program but i dropped out essentially
for crypto and as things blew up so i
don't have any of the credentials that
some astrologers would consider like oh
you're uh registered through this
program you don't need them really to be
like
often your work and who you are speaks
for itself with what you can show so
what's what sign are you
i'm a virgo son
yeah i knew that
cool i totally saw that i was thinking
you'd be a virgo what sign oh you know
what sign i am but does it make sense to
you i'm a cancer do i do am i do i give
off cancer vibes oh i don't know if you
know this about me but cancer is
actually my favorite sign i get along
with cancer is the best so i saw that
and my heart was a little warm yeah yeah
cancers and scorpios are my favorites i
get along very well with water signs so
i saw that and was like okay that's
pretty cute um
i actually i don't know
very well so i'm going in intentionally
like when um i intentionally didn't want
to look too much into okay good that's
good great yeah like actually i don't
yeah so so let's just get right into the
reading i'm gonna be upfront i'm pretty
skeptical about all this so i hope you
don't take it uh personally if i should
be skeptical about new things i love i
don't want a blind believer person like
good that you're asking questions yeah
okay so
how so let me pull up my
star chart
okay i have yours
i'm a cancer obviously you have my
birthday
yeah and all that wait do i need this
link what does this link mean
that's in the doc
to your chart
yeah
i i don't know what it means but it
looks uh uh very complicated am i
supposed to pull this up though sure put
it on the screen let's take a look at
your chart okay so this is my chart so
we're here i'm gonna make it so she can
see so i mean
what what okay so tell me about myself i
guess
yeah so what we're looking at here are
all of the planets around the earth when
you're born so you can pretend that
we're in the center on the earth and
then all around us are the different
planets and they're all falling in
different areas of life known as the
houses and these houses are the areas of
life that show up as not just your
psychology and your personality but
things that happen to you so what we're
looking at is both your character and
life events happening to you and the one
area of your chart that is inherently
you is the first house which
in this chart the way that it's set up
frankly is a little confusing like i
don't have you the chart that you're
showing pulled up i have it pulled up in
like a software that's a little bit
easier to look at um but the first house
for you is aries also known as the
rising sign
and that rising sign is much more of
your personality and your character and
your vibe like you're if you were a meme
you would be memed as like what an aries
is basically so you're a cancer son
but you have an aries rising and aries
is a cardinal fire sign
it's um i like to say like courageously
impulsive because it's very immediate
and it tends to be
very good natured in how quickly
like aries energy acts so first and
foremost aries rising gives off this
very fiery very um
impression that's a bit more playful
than cancer on its own there's a bit
more ability to bounce off of other
people and other things where cancer on
its own can be a little bit more guarded
but you have a cancer sun mars
conjunction so with the planet mars say
that again
your sun and cancer is conjunct the
planet mars they're right on top of one
my son
yeah and my cancer
conjunct
so conjunct means on top of one another
so you have the sun and mars right next
to one another versus most people don't
have them anywhere near each other wow
okay
yeah
i heard you say something about
impulsive and that definitely tracks
with the ether that i know
you say okay he says stuff on a show
how am i impulsive i like impulsive is
like i'm going to [ __ ] vegas and
where i mean that literally happened on
the show today
we were talking about yeah we mentioned
vegas you were like i gotta go to vegas
don't say we were talking about going to
vegas
for a long time
you did it was about you think i'm
involved in me bringing it up i mean you
insisting that we're going to think i'm
not you are a little bit i'm impulsive
you've come in you're a responsible
adult who's got family and you're
grounded but i think you have that like
tendency yeah it's not like you know
it's not like a bad way no no no
i'm not taking as bad i'm just trying to
verify the uh
accuracy of on my star reading
i think i mean so far that's so fast
guys [ __ ] it let's stream on twitch
[ __ ] it let's go back that was all
within like a month
maybe maybe instead of impul impulsive
i'm fearless
yeah but you said that
did you say i'm fearless or it was
it was sort of i said that there's a
good natured ability to be courageous so
you could say that
i don't think i'd say fearless with a
cancer sun with cancer sun there's like
a
there's you're both
impulsive but at the same time you're
aware of the what you need to
be really really afraid of and concerned
with at the same time like you're not so
impulsive that you're going to go out
and totally [ __ ] yourself over like
you're going to be you're you're doing a
cold reading now
i think you're tapping into what we just
said
did we mention the rules well i can move
on then oh i won't oh yeah do you know
about buying a rolls-royce
what stands out to me
is like um
pretty like really good financial
indications i was like like he
that's what stands out to me like hugely
hugely um you have a really well
positioned five percent no no okay
i am rich but but like that's not a
secret so when you so there's obviously
a lot of people who are can't who are
cancers
so like what would that mean for like a
regular guy because we can't all be rich
right
right in your chart the most positive
planet in your chart is in the second
house of finances it's also conjunct
something called the north node which
represents huge increase and it's in a
configuration with another planet that
indicates a lot of uh benevolence coming
your way basically so without even
knowing your financial situation
automatically i'm seeing that the most
like huge huge um
huge indication that's where my that's
where the configuration goes up points
out to me the most is uh financially
also getting helped out by um
connections at the right place at the
right time from people who might be from
another country
or are
people that you can't even speak about
not in a bad way but like there's like a
country
well love is from another
your wife is from another country oh
well
that didn't happen like you can't say my
whole life this is a reading i'm just
saying okay when you're giving me this
reading are you talking about my whole
life or is this like a forecast
so given that you're young
some of this will have already happened
and some will be related to the future
and um there's certain planetary suggest
like some of this like the money things
i can see wouldn't have probably been
clear
very early on but would have been
something that did emerge it's now more
so this isn't like a this isn't like a
month-to-month reading this is my life
reading you're saying that someone from
yeah month to month but right now i'm
looking at your life itself and what
that it what that holds so you're saying
someone from overseas is going to make
me very rich
accurate
i would say that
over the past year so 2021
that likely would have
been like highlighted uh but that it's
there's opportunity here especially over
the next year on it's not totally over
yet um but i'd say over the past year it
looks like that opportunity like someone
international like the two things is
this could be my wife is israeli does
that count
yes yes especially if that's and she
made me rich
then that fulfills this and that over
the past year that would have been like
the prophecy bro
you are the prophecy really you said the
biggest thing you're seeing in my chart
is that
as someone from overseas is going to
come and make me rich as [ __ ]
and that um i i didn't i mean you said
rolls-royce and it made sense because i
can see like you you know how to spend
well like that's pretty cool so that's i
don't know if that's spending wow
it's it's spending well like eating well
is you know what i mean like
fat
i'd say you just enjoy the finer things
to a very clear degree like it's there
yeah
it's not inaccurate
yeah and literally
venus in your chart is ruling your
second house of income and finances and
your seven house of marriage so it's
literally connecting marriage with like
what allows and facilitates
[Laughter]
okay
yeah that's very accurate
cool
but
you never seen this show
no i literally haven't uh i didn't know
anything and then i was mentioning that
it was on and i had people like i i
haven't so you can ask me like other
things as well completely blind um yeah
okay okay do you know if stick okay do
you
name one person who have you ever known
a man to stick his dick in a jar of
peanut butter
i've never encountered it
just
doing a what would be the sign of
somebody who would do that sagittarius
without a doubt
he's such a sagittarius okay wait wait
wait wait wait get back to jail
we gotta find out if he's a sad asap
craig okay
he's another tick talker that we spoke
with earlier in the episode who has a
sagittarius and a correction they're the
sexual ones right
um i wouldn't say that i would say
uh
the explorative ones the most important
oh that's exploration
yeah
okay
anything else about me i should know
um
well this upcoming year so this is a
forecast specifically for
this eclipse cycle in april and may and
then again in october november
you should
the world events will be destabilizing
for you but also lead to a lot of money
like in a really good way it's all about
money
but the eclipses for you
yeah really really financially strong so
that's something that i see as well
being important that's [ __ ] gold dude
[ __ ] the world pay me
is there anything i can do for my money
not to or my life to not to be totally
oriented by money
yeah i mean
you have a big focus like your son and
mars they're in your fourth house of
family or
being private so i can see that
guarding like making sure that you're
not over extending boundaries um and
that
like the i d what does the idea family
mean to you like is that something that
comes with a little bit of a like
a mixed bag it's kind of bittersweet um
is there a clear picture that comes up
for you when you think of the idea
family
uh
family family
family family
we got a big family yeah i mean i love
my family i have two sons i'm close with
my family it's all good
okay okay
yeah the other major focus besides
financial stability in your chart is
guarding family um it brings in like
setting up a lot of do you invest in
real estate
i i own some real estate
okay i see that um
connecting investing in and home
[Laughter]
yeah
i was looking up if because i wasn't
sure if i'm translating it correctly you
don't strike me as sad you don't [ __ ]
peanut butter
i have your chard as well all right
let's let's move on to ela who's a sad
okay well she has a sagittarius son but
you have an aquarius rising and aquarius
is your rising sign being more of like
what sugar coats or your personality and
how you
people vibe with you aquarius is
an air sign so it's intellectual and
it's a fixed sign so it's a little bit
calmer than sagittarius
aquarius tends to be nerdy open-minded
but serious so
they're great for conversation can be a
little bit like a loofer detached but
are much more
they're much easier and sorry for me
personally i find sagittarius is the
energy is more fun and out there and
aquarius is more open-minded but
grounded at the same time so you have a
good combination of the two because you
have both signs but off the bat you give
off more aquarius energy which is like
weird quirky uh but very intellectual
how do you feel
ish
do you feel that's accurate
what do you think
i don't think a lot of it is very
accurate in the sense that
uh i would say i i i don't even remember
there was a lot some struck me as
accurate some not
but what do you think what is aquarius
in hebrew oh yeah
in hebrew aquarius is oh
okay
that's okay
um
i don't know
say that part say all that again
you give off
even though your son is in sagittarius
which is adventurous what you more so
give off on a character level is being
open-minded serious a little nerdy but
very very
intellectual like you very intelligent
like number one thing i would describe a
lot of what i see here in your chart uh
all combined is
intelligence uh focus on being well
traveled um
not well traveled not intelligent
interesting i would say i would say that
you end up being very well traveled you
connect travel actually for you is
connected with um with
marriage or partnership oh oh
well i i had to move here maybe oh here
we go
but we're not but that's what we don't
try i mean yeah
we don't travel a lot i would say you
end up well traveled um that could be
some of these things like when you're
younger none of this can play out
by the time you're like that's true we
could be well traveled right yeah she
travels i mean she goes to see her
family every year that's a lot or
however often not what world travelers i
mean she's from the other side of the
world
i would consider that well like that's
like entered like yeah from here too are
you um i see and you're like birth right
you're born in tel aviv is that where
you're going to have to visit
yeah
i would consider that very well i mean
going back and forth like that's really
so i see long distance travel as being
in your chart basically as like a theme
so i'd say that that qualifies
yeah
are we okay okay it's a little stretch
traveling am i right not to be a hater
will traverse like i gotta go on
vacation i gotta travel i gotta see the
world
i can be articulating things poorly as
well that it can be on me no no no no no
no no you just you're the bat you're
listen i don't wanna be the [ __ ] here
i'm just saying
i think it depends how you look at it
because me living here for me feels a
little bit part of maybe what she's
talking about okay yeah the way that i'm
getting this is that the part of the
chart connected with identity is
connected to the travel and also the
marriage part of the chart so it's very
much like if you're familiar with first
order logic like if this than that then
i say this statement so if i'm off like
that's my error no
you're right again just trying to push
back
no totally totally i uh nobody's backing
me up here so
on my own
okay what else she's so she's a world
traveler
you're a uh
uh you're married to someone and caused
you to be a world traveler that's true
okay okay what else we got
off like that's
does that mean no sorry that was my
fault
no you're fine i just naturally i i
can't stand hearing my own voice like i
just let my
thing and if i have to listen to
anything i put it on like 3x speed
because not my not my thing um but in
your chart another thing that stands out
is
a combination of planets that are very
provocative and
aggressive and possibly an activism way
um with bridging being what do you have
a background in uh journalism or writing
no
okay do you do anything that's like
content based for like written work even
like short form
like with this it or is this the main uh
platform that you you do you do you
write little blurbs in your art
right but it's like four words four
words at most does that count yeah that
wouldn't really qualify thank you i just
i was testing you
to make sure you didn't accept that
no yeah there it's connecting
giving out information on a recurring
basis which i usually ask people are you
a journalist are you a writer do you
document things so giving out
information on a regular basis is
connected to career i usually don't lump
in podcasts with that uh because
i consider that a bit longer form uh so
i see probably maybe a different form of
information that's being given out
um in a career that could be
activism related could at least be just
provocative i'm not sure how like this
show is received if it tends to be
um something that is like i don't know
people are always like inflamed or if
it's more well-received and people know
what they're getting um
we have quite a few inflamed
you don't cause fl you don't cause the
flames i do not me you do yeah okay does
it matter if i piss off the world and he
loves my wife
she's just present all the time
but like i'd say provocative is the word
because it looks like you're provocative
well it gets them to think
um not like in a getting people to think
way of provocative um so i see that with
yeah with what ends up being said um
and this is something actually that
looks this year the eclipses will lead
you to
let go or
you're letting go of a certain aspect of
career that might require you to
highlight this more moving forward that
you're letting go of some of the more
like
things that you might be doing publicly
that just um
they don't feel like they need their an
energetic drain like you're like this
isn't really worth it and instead you're
leaning more towards things that seem to
be more regular delivery of this
information but are um
like it looks pretty provocative or
powerful can i ask you a question is
there ever bad news in the charts like i
see [ __ ] heart attack and there's all
there's always uh those positive
negatives do you see bad news in my
chart give me the bad news
um there's bad news in everyone's charts
yeah give me all the bad news in my
chart
this is why i like financial markets
because i can say it looks like [ __ ]
terrible and no one's like oh no you
hurt my feelings like that's why tell me
everything what's the bad news do you
see nuclear war
in your chart no i don't see that at
least
yeah
most challenging thing actually is
financial as well what the hell am i i'm
up i'm down i mean
well you end up being very good
financially but i can see as well that
possibly due to something in your career
and also like networking in your career
could lead you to
invest in a way that is more than just a
loss of money but is like really really
substantial like others wrong you really
substantially like kavanagh
does ryan cavanaugh look like
rvweinstein.com baby
would you consider being sued three
times four times four times absolutely
there you go all right well there you go
there you go
yeah yeah i was gonna ask if there were
like lawsuits involved or four of them
from the same guy
his name's ryan cavanaugh i was gonna
say or maybe you're a bad investing
uh well
i put money in the s p 500. that doesn't
count as bad that's not bad maybe maybe
the timing wasn't good but i'm not doing
like options right that doesn't count
right no when um she's a guru
are you are you more an expert trader or
an expert astrologer
um i wouldn't say i'm an expert at
either but i have many more years under
my belt with astrology but also i feel
more like with
trading um and like investing with
something that automatically
i just felt very um i can't give advice
or anything but it was something that
immediately clicked for me nice
so do you see any health issues am i
gonna have a heart attack or diabetes or
anything
um
no actually
pretty strong health indicators
right hamburgers tonight baby
yeah pizza for dinner
unstoppable
i think over the past year
um over the past year the most positive
transfer has actually been through like
mental health and that like awareness of
things growing more and
then over the summer there's um pretty
like actually positive health things in
your life hell yeah i yeah i will say
that
the because everyone has health issues
shown in their chart that
for you it might be um
digestive issues passed down through
your family that it's connecting like
yes
can i can just the stars does it start
to say what i should have for dinner
no i can't answer that that's not my
expertise but it seems like they're not
cautioning against like mexican or pizza
or anything like that it's definitely
not saying salad
i'm not getting i'm not getting any
caution signals against any food group
[Music]
i love astrology
this shit's real i knew it
all right did love have um shake shack
oh yeah we were wondering love was
saying he's sorry
it's okay we got on the topic of food
yeah we were wondering did you want
in-n-out shake shack or mexican say
exactly is that okay
yeah because you got shake shack once
and you didn't like it
oh yeah i did actually
but i found that so odd well let's get
both let's get both
okay i'm not going to say no to that
yeah
was shake shack and an in and out yeah
both that's one of buzzfeed's most is
have you had in and out have you been
out to the west coast thoughts on in and
out i've never had in and out do they
have any vegan options
oh they they have options i was vegan
for three years and if you ask them for
a veggie burger they will give you bread
with veggies
horrible yeah i mean to be honest i
enjoyed it
okay i guess if you just try it every
time i visited so that's been my i like
so basically difficult but like where
yeah cafe gratitude i love traffic
gratitude
good yeah it sounds like a place i'd be
angry at
gratitude you have a son mars
conjunction i'd say you have a little
bit of like like like you're always like
there's a little bit of a uh like
similar to i wouldn't say provocatively
because i think that that's better
reserved for the other situation i was
saying but you have like a um a
well-meaning aggression towards you like
you like to you like
and i'll tell you what it's not
well-meaning either
okay i was trying to be charitable there
but we don't it's angry
ethan you would you would hate cafe
gratitude i [ __ ] i just hate it by
the name every single item on the menu
is like i am grateful i am beautiful
i'm not ordering i'll be pissed off
when you order but i got an angry shake
and a [ __ ] the best busy i always i
order and i say can i please have i am
grace and i say you are grace
i know i am not grace
don't give me that [ __ ]
can i can you get me an eternal
damnation burger
people say ethan rip ass at cafe
gratitude
[Laughter]
i would totally rip ass at cafe
gratitude
yeah no i uh shout out the food's good
there it's vegan
yeah i mean i love it it's like
bowls of things it's very like hearty
options so what's your favorite dish
there what's its name
i don't remember but it's a sweet potato
curry because i know that whenever
places have that
maybe it's called like happy uh bowel
movement
well and i've had i've had some of their
like cheesecakes and those are good as
well
yeah i'm gonna check it out dan's gonna
read the menu to us right now
i'm actually curious on some of these
now i'm hungry and it's later eastern
time
i'm sorry what's in your hands do you
have any what does anyone here have
anything we should be worried about in
their charts let's just go to the
negative because that's interest more
okay
what's the most alarming chart yeah
um i have like 10 of them so honestly i
mean i i it's not like i i just inputted
them i didn't really take a look at them
because i usually like to speak on them
just like when i see them flat out
i have a good angle that we can take um
uh there's one for a guy named zach
we've previously done not astrology but
some we had a psychologist come onto the
show about a year ago and do an analysis
on all of us and he was off the charts
but always in your heart on narcissism
scale like uh and like basically he told
us that zach was a sociopath so i'm kind
of curious if his chart aligns yeah you
gave away too much dan well well of
course it does now not necessarily i i
wouldn't even i don't i don't even
though i have a background in abnormal
psychology i don't ever go as far to
like say like you could call him
his chart though yeah before you say it
yeah i have his chart pulled up
september 22nd 97. give us all the
negative stuff of zach just just lay it
on let me know what an [ __ ]
um
well immediately what i'd say is that he
gives off
fairly grounded stable vibes but
actually in relationships um
like all of his relationships seem to be
very very intense there's an obsessive
quality especially um
it's almost like a bad habit or an
addiction that um
yeah but not no way that's like
unbearable or really out of the it's not
something where i'm cheating we need uh
we need um
chantal here though
what do you think so i'm in that fast
and smell test
i mean i
think it depends depends on who i mean
i i guess in the past but
that is something i've kind of like
worked on
[Music]
yeah it's not bad i mean i see i like
it's a very intense thing i'd say that
um a lot of the chart focus does go on
one-to-one relationships and some of
those are with people that like are
it's connecting co-workers like people
that you've worked with um
and
yeah yeah it's connecting people that
you work with there's focus on that as
well like i'd say hard-working okay
that's that when's he gonna die let's
cut to the chase is he gonna i don't
know that actually
should he watch out for mcdonald's does
it say anything about a joker brain
say anything about a rolex in there
there's financial indications here that
are pretty strong as well like very
similar yeah yeah are you a similar
outlook than me you know that's [ __ ]
no it's not actually the most positive
parts of this chart are even with the
difficulties of relationships it is
actually like relationships look like
they end up being the most positive when
like one person is landed on and is more
substantial also like
kurt
like i said hard working stands out here
um
really far-reaching career that takes a
little bit of time to get going but
i think
cameo this is the end of the road here
wait wait what did you say a
hard-working career that takes a little
time
yeah like the career aspect takes some
time to land on but i'd say over the
past year there's been
hardships what are you doing you're
trying to get my guy to leave his job
um i think i mean i see i don't see him
ending up i see him working for himself
what are you gonna do
zach's gonna be a rock star one day zach
you're gonna be a rock star i'm good
you're saying here appreciate that he he
is actively trying to be a that's the
only job you can leave that i'd be fine
with zach well i would never leave if
that there you go just equality like i
was like if this person's not already
doing something that's quite like i
guess disruptive to the industry that
you're in you're gonna disrupt what do
you mean by this is really inherently
disruptive like the a planet that
symbolizes uh being rebellious or
disruptive steve jobs bro like [ __ ]
he disrupted them yeah good it's in a
good way you're disruptive i'm gonna
[ __ ] [ __ ] up a joker brain a joker
are you saying i'm going to [ __ ] [ __ ] up
it's a yes or no question yes
okay
okay
all right i asked for negative and now
now you just turn into all this nice
stuff me and dan kind of had a question
i don't know yeah
me and dan are born at the same time
yeah does that mean anything are you
guys at the same birthday what are you
doing at the same time yeah different
birthday
okay
let me comment on that as someone who
said two kids
they just write that [ __ ] in it's not
it's not accurate they go what was it uh
10 15 uh
it's not accurate at all to the second a
minute damn i thought
i thought we had something i thought
like i'm just saying because people go
people always go i was bored at 745 on
the dot it's like no you weren't that
[ __ ] is not accurate it's a red flag to
me as well whatever someone has a
rounded birth time if i pull up their
chart and it's on the border of being
like another sign because it's it
changes every two hours i will ask them
like are like i'm like this is a rounded
time and they'll often say like no i'm
like i don't i don't care i'm going to
need to do some back testing on your
life to verify like if it you know is
the right time or not because it's a
recording as well can i ask something
my on my birth certificate of the time
at least i was told my birthday is 9 22
and it said i was born at 9 22 at night
now
you said that turns into a different
sign or
am i so
with astrology we're looking at the
houses which are sections of the sky and
planets fall into these sections of the
sky the earth rotates in a way that each
house changes signs every two hours
so if you're born at one of the borders
of the rough two-hour period even though
your planets will likely be in the same
sign as anyone else born that day the
exact uh placement of them in the chart
can change which changes the entire way
that i would predict someone's life
because the houses are the areas of life
so if someone is on the border i'm even
if they're not on board on a rounded
time i do tell them flat out i'm like
i'm going to ask some preliminary
questions that are major like either yes
or no and if it's a yes or no one way
then it helps me determine okay
yeah
interesting you had a question what was
your question
my question is something that i could
probably just google but i figured i'd
just ask you um
when
because you were talking about uh with
ela
aquarius uh as her rising sign and uh
and then you mentioned it was an air uh
sign um
why it's it's aquarius aqua
yeah so
the word represents the water bearer so
it's a human so someone with an
intellectual
ability that is offering water or giving
sustenance which represents aquarius
being someone who
develops conversations and ideas and
allows others to build on top of them so
there's like a provider quality to
aquarius it's
aqua comes from being the water bearer
or the bearer of gifts and ideas rather
than actual like
water yeah that messed me up because my
wife is an aquarius and i'm a pisces i
always thought it was fish and water and
then i found out it's air and water i
mean air and fish yeah yeah there's some
water it's like fish to water
good question though
i'm a [ __ ] crab what does that do for
me
i'm a crab too you're cancer we're crab
buddies you guys are crabby sometimes i
don't like well
i think energetically turtle is like an
actual like more spot-on cancer metaphor
because turtles are like they hide in
their shell and then they come out when
they feel safe so that's more so what i
think but crap
turtle in that regard like that's my
defining attribute loving aries right am
i hiding in myself apparently the rising
so the the from what i'm understanding
what she's saying is like your main sign
that everybody knows their sign is sort
of like your internal uh personality and
then what you put out
okay so it depends on where it is in
your chart
for everyone
i'm a cancer but i'm not a cancer
retro and mercury retrograde we got
eclipses it's a lot well yeah yeah it is
um
and
the
like the astrology side of it that i'm
looking at in someone's chart is where
are those energies falling in different
areas of life so like your cancer energy
is falling around home and family like
that's a major focus in your chart so
the rising sign for everyone is always
personality character kind of their vibe
but the sun sign
might be more internal it might be more
external it might refer to something
else entirely in the chart and um
with looking at astrology we're being
very specific so if i'm wrong i'm wrong
literally being specific like i'm not
talking about generalities here um let
me ask you yeah so
when we're looking at the stars
we know
that the whole astrology system
100 000 or 100 million years ago was
completely different the signs were
different in the night sky how does that
affect your study
so we we're looking at where the planets
are and there's different ways of
calculating it um based on the
procession of the equinoxes which is the
fact that the earth
its axis is wobbling in a way that
changes our relation to planets and
stars a little bit each year so there
are multiple different ways to calculate
where we are but none of it is
inaccurate it's just simply a different
locus of where you're measuring it from
are you measuring straight to the fixed
stars are you measuring it based on the
seasons and that starting point so it's
all i mean what i'm the program i'm
using has a nasa data api so
they're different calculations and some
people who want to make it seem like
their calculation is the right one will
claim that the other one is inaccurate
when in reality just depends on the
point that you're measuring from on
earth but everything is a valid
calculation
is that why the star system is gone
is that why the star system was
different then or was it because i mean
it's it's the equinox it moves like that
like that like 100 it also moves apart
that's a different thing yeah yeah yeah
i mean all the the data like real-time
data so things do change from thousands
of years ago but we're we're calculating
the change no but i'm talking about like
hundreds of millions of years ago would
that change the effect
so would a cancer a cancer would be a
[ __ ]
pisces
yeah we calculated differently all right
i got it now let me ask you another
question
how does how do the stars affect our
personality what how it don't affect
anything it's all like correlation not a
causation so i like to say instead of
affecting it's mirroring um kind of like
how the clock on the wall is not telling
you that it's 5 pm it is or not making
it 5 pm it's telling you that it's 5 pm
so there's no effect there's no cause
it's all correlation and i think that
that's really important to highlight
because people will try to make a straw
man argument to make astrologers um
sound really really crazy and say that
mars isn't making anything happen i'm
like yeah you're [ __ ] right mars is
not making anything happen but a certain
position you can see world events that
coincide with that so it's not affecting
anything all right okay wait let me
unpack that
so the stars are a mirror
that tell us
what's going on in the earth
exactly so how does that how do you read
that how does the stars
reflect what's happening on earth
i'd say that the fact that so many
cycles can be seen and mirrored with
great specificity
raises larger questions as to there
being a more complicated framework to
reality than just us living randomly on
earth so i don't see it as something we
need to solve but rather it humbles us
that we don't have it all figured out
because if there's a kind of code to the
matrix that we're seeing here that is
not pulled out of thin air it's not like
i the argument for finding patterns
where there's not is a great one to make
sure that we're not doing that but based
on the specificity of certain patterns
especially financially that are black
and white i mean number go up go down
kind of thing that raises larger
questions to the nature of reality um
and studying astrology helps us realize
that more and more
so in short you don't know why
it does it but it's something you've
observed
there is no why because it's not causal
by any measure we don't have any
indications well clearly there would be
an explanation if let's say we had all
the knowledge in the universe exactly
but
you don't have access to it
exactly
if you were a caveman and your currency
was like shiny rocks or pebbles or some
[ __ ] you would see that in the stars if
you were like i just found a [ __ ]
bomb
shiny ass shell
that would be in the stars
we're not just talking about crypto i
can always see where the planets are and
there are
like both general world events that will
be good or bad for the market like if i
see a lot of shaky events financially
versus like that can be in general and
i'll be able to see so that wouldn't
affect the caveman's shiny shell
necessarily i would that would because
that would be the economy whatever the
measurement of wealth is at the time
i interpreted that as saying if world
events are shaky that's obviously going
to affect the stock market but if you're
a caveman and then world let's say a
volcano is about to explode and cover
the world now that pebble is still going
to be there and he's about to get paid
well if i'm looking at like a specific
asset in this case like pebbles i'd want
the birth chart of the first person to
find the pebble in the village and like
use it like bitcoin i use the genesis
block like that's bitcoin's birthright
that's how i get the exact like
calls for that okay
yeah
someone said the gayest sign is pisces
is that true
that's just a comment i read i think
it's an interpretation
i'm a pisces so whatever that does for
you guys
interesting
i just read that and i thought it was i
don't know if that was uh it was just
kind of yeah i don't i don't have a data
set for that okay doesn't say anything
about sexual orientation
we can see tendencies in the chart like
really how gay am i
um or i'd say like there are certain
indications of being counter cultural
with one sexuality so depending on the
upbringing that i see i can kind of
piece that together also if you're more
committed or you're more um like paulie
that's something that can be tell me
tell me tell me tell me what's my um did
you looking at your chart doesn't that
make you gay
we'll see
now you you ten i'd say i'd say you look
for more
what about ela
let me see her chart
a little bit more like counter cultural
but that doesn't mean that she herself
is like like i'd say that you're more
with with what you're doing in
relationships you're more still making a
statement that is
let's go
so you're saying there's a chance
what are we
girl on girl
i wouldn't say it shows that like you're
like uh
i'd say it just looks more like you're
more willing to make a statement in
relationships
come on dude
yeah all right thank you
uh thank you so much for sharing your
knowledge with us
yeah thank you for having me actually
it seems like mine was really accurate
and yeah just just so you know not all
of us are such skeptics a lot of us uh
believe no i mean i am a skeptic about
my own work until it like i think it's
very good i think what do you mean by
that
well i'm just saying i commend her for
coming on and you know some of us here
believe it more than others
are you talking for yourself i believe
it yes i believe it she changed my mind
why do you have to say it like that i
mean just
no yeah i'm happy to come on i
i know the trap a lot of or not trap but
a lot of times when put on the spot
there can be
trying to turn it down or be general so
i try to be as specific as possible but
yeah what i focus on is mainly like
financial markets because that's where i
can be like no i said number go up and i
was wrong or i send up like it was it's
very like clear so
where should people put their money
right now and crypto or the stock market
on a personal level i always say crypto
because that means that you hold more
personal ownership of yours that means
your crypto goes up
no because i'm in stable coins so far i
don't know uh and i don't put like my
wallet's public you can always see what
i'm doing so i'm not like
have you heard of uh have you heard of
ding dong
no it's an exciting or
no coin opportunity yeah milk and paul
mill are tits coins or any of that [ __ ]
you follow those
i can't really talk about it because
then it just people are like you're paid
i'm like no i just oh yeah
i can't talk about my small investments
actually like it literally ethically i
can't so yeah check out think the link i
think you'll be interested in that one
were you paid to say that or was it no
no no no no it's just i think it's a
huge opportunity these memes they will
stay can we pay you to like casually
mention they're [ __ ] no i know i know
they're it's crazy i agree the the
shitcoin meme coin market is is scary
it's crazy yeah it is it is well um guys
if you're interested
to follow more
this is um
what's your tick tock name it's uh aaron
altman everything's just nice marion
altman and you're on youtube and stuff
and all that yeah i am i just a year
late because of cover delays i got my
100k plaque like hey
congratulations
yeah they i arrived in the mail and i
remember like two years ago they were
like uh we have delays and shipping two
years wow wow yeah
but we made it we made it
well marin thanks for coming and
spending your time with us it was fun
and i appreciate that so guys check out
marin altman
uh thank you so much peace and love take
care
yeah yeah and i mean really good
information about
either the next time you call me fat i'm
just kidding you don't do that
next time he goes put down the fork
fatty i'll be like marin said i'm gonna
live forever
also by curious shout out to by curious
ela what do you want
what is this
have you visited blocked
yeah
what do you want i'm just playing
yeah i've never seen the chat split like
that
half the chat i believe half was
extremely against it so i mean listen
hers was pretty accurate against me
where i was like come on
but you know
it's a
wait mine was accurate completely mine
was
she's like you're rich your wife is
gonna be your wife is gonna be from
overseas and she's gonna make you rich
and then she's like you could care about
your family i was like whoa
that's insane
i think she changed my mind i was a
little bit of a skeptic but
it just seems very positive you know i
literally said he tells that you're all
the negatives she told you to be rich
and successful zach
i kind of believe in this stuff now i
never i never
i don't know it just seems like look if
it makes you happy then what the [ __ ]
yeah no it's harmless it's not like
organized religion where they're like
burn
pay me or burn in hell at least not that
i know
but the crypto stuff i think it's pretty
scary to promote crypto
well i think it's pretty funny to think
that the astrology affects crypto that
personally fascinates me well i just
people believe that in this a lot and i
i'm invested in crypto but i know
i would never invest money that i can
afford to lose you know
well she didn't that money can be gone
whenever
but i feel like she's not giving that
the claim disclaimer
i'm being a hater sorry yeah
i'm not gonna go that hard on her
but i wouldn't necessarily want i mean
that's one type of crypto guru there's
one for everyone one gets their advice
from the stars one gets their advice
from garyvee
and one gets their advice from me and i
say don't buy it
and dan who says cardano all the way
no
the uh the thing about the uh
predicting uh the markets
there's probably about as much
validity to reading the stars to tell
you how the crypto market is going to go
than any of these dudes on youtube who
yeah she's probably just as that's what
is gary v exactly
i was watching that tim dillon gary v
impression last night again it's so
funny that's funny oh now you're gonna
walk to ukraine i mean how many miles is
that imagine how many tick tocks you
could make
be a millionaire by the time you reach
poland
gary always shows his impersonators he
always
like promotes them on his tick tock yeah
yo apparently gary vee like left his now
i'm speculating but he posted a picture
on instagram he's like a hot young girl
and he's like you make me so happy and
apparently has a wife and kids and
people like whoa bro what happened
that beef happened that the friends
changed you
that nft restaurant changed you bro oh
jesus can you pull that up
you can you make out with your dad once
and you think you're odd [ __ ]
it is incredible how many um he just
posted out of nowhere by the way like
people thought he was still with his
wife i think so yeah and i i tried to
look into it a little bit and there
isn't really like
there was a lot of
articles about it but it was all just
like kind of
gossip blog type of stuff there's no
actual like well show me that first of
all the the post the instagram post yeah
you sent it you sent me this video of a
of a 15 year old with braces gossiping
about
oh thank you but
you don't know who my source was on that
yeah i didn't i know i shared it because
it was on my page i didn't say
so here he is
with like a young beautiful model
and the caption is you make me so deeply
happy
and then people like wait you didn't
even say talk about your wife and kids
like that
now all of a sudden
yeah let's take a look no hate against
her of course
she says i'm extremely passionate about
wellness clean living self growth
culture and family yeah that's right up
his alley
let me tell you something
uh uh
imagine imagine
imagine falling off a bridge every
morning for 10 hours
here she is with garyvee this was from
february 20th
life with you is beautiful i'm sure it
is
i'm sure it is beautiful isn't it
you think garyvee gives good d
garyvee has good d good d
i i was thinking i was thinking of
something but i don't know if i should
say it
oh you know you got to say it now but
you know he says he's like yeah you know
i think about shooting my wife in the
face he's doing a different kind of
shooting in the face with it now imagine
yourself shooting your load every mo
that's disgusting
[Laughter]
every morning
how many i just i'm sorry but it's like
the typical rich guy
leaves his [ __ ] white old ass wife
gets a hot model girlfriend again these
are all just rumors but the rumors all i
mean
saying that the wife was leaving him oh
okay
well it's definitely not his wife though
right no it's his girlfriend okay
yeah i guess you never know no i don't
she left him his wife
again these are just rumors though
there's no uh public uh
official statement so anyway here's the
15 year old's take on it i'm extremely
confused oh it's confused i'm [ __ ]
did and so i guess a lot of people are
like wait didn't gary have a wife and
two kids yeah i guess a lot of people
because he was like yo imagine killing
your wife and your two kids every
morning i do that because i wish i was
single so bad that i can't it's the only
thing that gets me through the day i
want to [ __ ] hot babes okay now the guys
that that
like garyvee here
tell me if i'm wrong or not but wasn't
like family life and
stability a big part of like his
guru-ness like
i honestly i don't think i'm well-versed
enough to say i mean i'm not your
therapy staff no no you guys label me
when i say them like
one day
see
yeah people i'm definitely not a fan but
i have defended some of the takes that
he has had
like
i don't remember
but yeah i'm not a big fan but yeah he's
a lot about family and [ __ ] like that
sure maybe just talking about making out
with his dad more
that's probably it
that's what i watch
that's that's the content
he flipped them after buying them he
said here's the comments
so the text says anyone else thought
gary vee had a whole wife and two kids
top commenters he flipped them after
buying them at the orphanage
you have to flip the first wife and kids
they're going to continuously decrease
in value and eventually i'll have to
flip this one too brutal
it's true actually
i mean
from his perspective
careful he says no he does i've
literally seen him in his family at my
grandparents condo in florida
you've seen him at your grandparents
condo
he turned his family into nfts and sold
them for 3e
he found a new perspective yeah
he flipped him everybody's just saying
he flipped him
he really is the king of trades
i imagine shooting my wife and two kids
every morning in fact i dream about
dating hot models i'm so rich it's just
an injustice this is the only thing that
gets me through today i imagine okay go
home imagine shooting your wife for kids
and then [ __ ] a hot young babe that's
what i do that crypto [ __ ]
there you go someone said not anymore
they weren't making content
he sold him for 98.
it's like the one guy you thought was
genuine and loved his wife sold out to
fame interesting
i gotta say as as a woman
just seeing all these guys trade out
their wives for young models it's just
kind of gross you just right it's very
gross
pretty temple you just said did i do it
i would say if
i ask you
listen
as a
as a woman
how do you feel about it as a woman you
know what they say uh well i behaved
women
i was leading to asking the ladies i
will tell you after having two kids now
that if you left me and then dated a
young model i will be very pissed it's
fine
and it happens so often it's like i also
see that somebody like some random
comment but somebody said that
it's kind of weird that he never posted
his wife yeah for like privacy yeah
she's not in the limelight a lot i'm
saying but he does credit her for a lot
of his success and moral support it says
in a lot of his uh conferences but she
stopped sucking my dick and so that
that's gonna be a problem
i'm flipped her to this hot young model
just saying i feel like she probably
left him if she left him then i'll [ __ ]
him i feel like it's bad more likely
why do you think that's more likely
apparently their relationships are weird
imagining her being shot
that's exactly what i said she's like
all right here actually here this is uh
the this is a recent photo he actually
it's a uh
now oh with the dad yeah oh this is sick
manager
[Laughter]
uh
we we
we troll garyvee we we do a little trick
he got so popular 10 million followers
[Music]
watch some of his conferences he's given
great advice i got to say like i haven't
again i have been watching the recent
stuff bro i challenge you to show me
unique good advice he gives
let's do it why don't you show us a good
i
about this guy so i hate him already
yeah okay but i've never seen the good
stuff i agree bring hit the best of the
best check out tv [ __ ] and let's do a
let's do a fair imbalance
he posts a lot though most of it doesn't
have that many views
this guy posts like a [ __ ] monster
bruh
this guy posts like he changes wives no
i'm kidding he only did it once
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah
shout outs
we like to troll
that's a lot to say though
i wonder how long they've been dating
because he's like you make me so
deeply oh my god dude i can't handle
this photo
i'm inventing the next version of the
screwdriver then i'm using it dude i'm
sorry but what a [ __ ] douche
was this santa's a good one or a battery
himself
hi lopez was betting that but who pulled
this up
cam this was dead
this guy is
i'm inventing the next screwdriver then
i'm using it quote that's why tyler ty
lopez was doing this he was posting oh
yeah original quotes with pictures of
himself
of stuff he said posting it himself and
i always thought i was like this is
embarrassing yeah and i'm realizing that
this is a [ __ ] garyvee thing and by
the way
this only has 70 likes on it
who wants to lose some money today why
does it only happen
this is for 2016.
you know it's probably not a good quote
if you got to quote us yourself like
wait what was that
um
i'm inventing new sex toys and shoving
him up my own ass
he's live with milk right now he's live
with milk let's go
i'm seeing no it's gabe i thought it was
gary vee too oh gabe
gabe who
like white claw game yeah
i'm looking betrayed wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait what
that can't be really
i just accidentally liked the garyvee
post i don't know where the [ __ ] it just
wait wait stop i need games let's shut
up about garyvee
av needs to unlike
yeah i don't care
i went on both the profiles i'm not
seeing it i'm on milk i went on white
claw gabe
where are people where do we people keep
saying gabe live on elk
channel
did you check his youtube their youtube
channel this is the full sign let me try
and let me check full sense you didn't
check that that'd be the first place to
look bro they got us no they didn't
they're saying it just ended damn
hopefully someone recorded that
hopefully told him to piss in his ass or
something
i do have to tell you the chat has been
very good for us to talk about the
cayman kanye topic okay yeah that's for
next week
[Laughter]
no i can't put this off anymore you know
i don't know if you heard but it was
we've been using the same title of our
lives you see it in the chat i'm
learning monday wednesday and friday i
never got to it
so
this is our last chance
we have been going for three hours
maybe we should wrap it up no no no oh
it's five already yeah it's five o'clock
we gotta end this no we have to talk
it's a pretty long segment dude i think
we should end it let's save it for how
long are we gonna leave my mom with uh
no help
i'm sorry to her but we're talking about
this we're still we're still waiting on
food anyway so yeah
all right let's talk let's go
all right so you've got
i mean i feel like i should stop calling
pete davidson ski because i'm doing
kanye's bidding
don't do it he's i'm not using ski
can i just say before we even get into
this can we not
like
take a side in this can we just
like
why because i really don't think that
there's any good guys in this story i'm
not saying that there's good people but
there's one abusive side that's very
apparent for sure
that's all by the way three the texts
that pete sent kanye were also kind of
unhinged yeah yeah that's what i'm
saying i was like this dude this dude
branded the girl's
name who's been dating for a month on
his [ __ ] body and got two tattoos
well and then he sent it to kanye said
i'm [ __ ] your wife yeah
and kim kardashian
is
human scum as well so it's just like and
that doesn't justify what he's doing to
her at all and i do think that you know
in this story that we're about to talk
about he is the villain but like
no no team pete no team kim no no teams
olivia are you going to be able to know
where the police here
then he's skeed again [ __ ] him he's
skeed
um pete has talked about he has bpd
which like one of the
well we've heard that before
yeah in terms of like relationships he's
talked about how when they start a
common
p is falling
a common thing is like love bombing and
getting attached very easily so i think
that
those are possible indications of
that
um
i honestly thought that the text i mean
like kanye had been going at it for so
long yeah that's what i was gonna say
too that like those texts i was like i
was like go skeet how much can you push
somebody and then not eventually react
you never got to be more mature than
that yeah you do
but
well let's get into the topic well so
there you go dan you're [ __ ] uh
there's we have team beat
no i'm no i'm not olivia is team b i'm
team no abusing no abuser i also stand
on team
taco bell bro
i'm team uh suspend kanye for good oh
but olivia is
expressly
team skeet i'm pretty team skeet okay
yeah
and i am pretty s team you were
here all right so one of pete's close
friends and collaborators released some
text messages
first of all the fact that pete's friend
released these makes me think that pete
davidson thought these were hella funny
and then hat told his friend to leak it
like why would his friend leak it
without his permission no it's no i
don't think he is
pretending that it's without his
permission he said that he leaked he
deleted his instagram or something he
has no socials right now pete
okay so he's so his friend
yeah so that's cringy as [ __ ] like
you're not being like epic own you're
being super cringe bro
he said yo it's skeet
can you please take a second and calm
down it's 8 am and it don't got to be
like this kim is literally the best
mother i've ever met what she does for
those kids is amazing
listen kim might be a good mother but
she ain't the best mother of all time i
could already say that whatever oh right
okay fair enough we don't know anything
you're right but good point
well there's that
uh what it what she does for those kids
is amazing and you are so [ __ ] lucky
that she's your kid's mom i've decided
i'm gonna let you treat i'm not gonna
let you treat us this way anymore and
i'm done being quiet grow the [ __ ] up
so far good i mean i would have said the
same thing
yeah that's fair this is fair right
do we all agree this is fair yeah yeah
if
now
is if he doesn't as if yeah you aren't
you know he's like hedonistic [ __ ]
human beings no it's like making him
feel like a kid that's what it was he's
like oh kid you're using profanity now
anyway obviously kanye's being a douche
uh he says in bed with your wife where
are you right now in bed with your wife
so yeah this was unnecessary
and this picture is kind of infuriating
to be honest
happy to see you're out of hospital in
rehab of course kanye always thank you
again
what can you expect i mean seriously
same here it wonders what those places
do when you go get help you should try
it i'm in la for the day if you want to
stop being a little internet [ __ ] boy
talk so
fine keith offered skeet offer to me you
don't scare me bro your actions are so
[ __ ] and embarrassing it's so sad to
watch you ruin your legacy on the daily
you're more than welcome to come to
sunday service again it's like no
you want to talk sunday service is not
where you go to talk it's not some kind
of a private thing that is just you
and your family yeah it's not come to my
cult meeting yeah
the cult that i run why don't you come
here where i have like guest appearances
right and it's like highly like uh
viewed by a lot of people i mean let's
go have a talk man to men there i got to
stay in service after all the [ __ ]
talking kanye's done which is an
enormous amount
pete literally said let's meet up and
then kanye
dodged
so [ __ ] move on kanye's part yeah i'll
only meet you at at the place where
people are literally gathered to worship
me yeah and i know he wouldn't frame it
that way it's it's about god to him but
no that's not what's going on he is god
yes exactly the answer is pete says
this is in public dude as he posts it
yeah right i am not i am not here for
pictures and press which is obviously
all you care about my offer stands i
wish you'd man up for once in your life
does that is that fair to say i wish
you'd man up for once in your life ian i
mean you're familiar with this history i
feel like kanye's probably manned up
before this oh i knew that was coming
i thought i was dodging i was like
everyone inside this is crazy i might
get out of it what are you afraid
no but like you're you're familiar with
this history like he's definitely manned
up before right wait what is the
question who kanye yes amanda pete said
to kanye i wish you'd man up for once in
your life
i mean kanye's never really been like um
like a tough guy character i don't i
don't really i don't know
um
yeah i don't know he he complains online
a lot but he's never been that guy i
don't think he's ever really pretended
to be that guy until very recently so
i don't know not that guy pal trust me
you're not that guy
uh he says let me help you man i
struggle with mental stuff too you're
it's not an easy journey this part gets
a little annoying you don't have to feel
this way anymore it's no shame in having
a little help you'll be so upbeat peace
the thing is positive message but in the
framing it's not a nice message no yeah
you have no idea how nice i've been to
you despite your actions towards me i
stopped snl from talking about or making
fun of you which they've wanted to do
for months i've stopped stand up
comedians
by the way i've stopped stand up
comedians from doing bits about you
because i don't want the father or my
girl's kid to look do you really think
he has that pull he's like yo i'm
stopping everybody from talking about
you kind of a [ __ ] like
probably not true and also a little
arrogant to think you have that
influence
over the programming of snl and i mean
he's a big star on s and all but even
like
if you were
a stand-up and pete davidson walked up
to you and was like hey can you not make
fun of kanye wouldn't you you'd be like
laughing on their face i'm not doing
that like what
what are you thinking
[Laughter]
i've got nothing
i have your back even though you treat
me like [ __ ] because i want everything
to be super if you continue to press me
like you have for the past six months
i'm going to stop being nice
i mean it's not very productive message
it's angry and warranted
why did he release this
yeah i don't know why did he really
thought he looked good
and kanye looked about
i find it weird that he thought this
made him look so good i mean it doesn't
let me seem like him look like bad
necessarily but it's not great
olivia it just
is showing himself taking the bait a
little bit right with like the picture
like [ __ ] your wife
right i forgot the
his friend leaked these and kanye didn't
post these
that changes it right that does change
it
yeah i mean i don't know why you're
saying leaked though he asked his friend
yeah
apparently yeah yeah for all
he posted it yeah you know that's the
short version yeah he posted this
publicizing it even further i mean i
don't really know if
more attention will
change the situation at all but like
calling more attention to it is just
contributing to the problem right
yeah and i mean up until this
he was definitely taking up the high
road yeah not talking about it
and now he's giving everybody like
if anything more ammunition like the
people on kanye's side because they're
like oh why is he calling why did he say
i'm [ __ ] your wife when she just
officially divorced kanye and she's not
his wife you know true
yeah there were i mean
kanye took so many jobs before but like
there were a lot of jabs in his texts
that i'm sure provoked kanye
very much like when he was like uh well
obviously he was in bed with his girl
but when he was like my girl's kids like
i don't want anyone messing with my
girl's kids like
i don't know i can't it's like that's
their dad yeah exactly
yeah
you know and i find it just a little
very obnoxious he goes this isn't public
dude
and then post the whole thing that's the
part when i read it i was like wait
these texts are blue like these were
screenshots taken by pete and then
posted
here's the thing if he would have been
really mature and nice and just wanting
to like be peaceful and then kanye was
being a total dick that would have been
different
well that's what it looked like up until
this was released
you know but yeah he could have been
antagonizing him a lot behind the scenes
that we didn't know
but i still feel like
even with all that pit is
way better in this situation than
kanye's definitely one hundred percent
tony's trying to like threaten to kill
him and [ __ ] yeah
like
by the way even if nobody's really
taking that seriously it's still a
[ __ ] up thing to say no i mean
in this
scenario kanye is obviously the abuser
here and obviously the one most in the
wrong it just happens
like
i hate to compare it to this but like
when we were talking about like the jeff
thing and it's like
jeff
can uh
you know have been severely wronged by
david but still
be kind of an [ __ ] you know what i
mean like it you both things can be true
and i think that's the case here where
it's like i don't like pete davidson and
kim kardashian i think that they suck
but they still don't deserve to have
this happen to them that doesn't that
doesn't justify it so
yo i need this clip of dl huey av
talking about deal huey
healy
isn't he hugely
what did i say duo hewley oh huly that's
what i said okay never mind give me a
break dude
so then obviously kim
kanye is not just even beefing with pete
at this point
i don't know why he went so hard after
this dude
d.l hewley
um but he has just gone nuts for this
guy
[Music]
uh
first he starts doxxing him i'll we're
gonna pull up the clip of what dl said
but it wasn't like that bad it's kind of
on par with what everyone's saying
he posted this picture to instagram
what
dl lives in calabasas yo god is good
god is good he put he yo his house is in
striking distance
god is so good he's gonna allow me to
kill this man yeah so good by the way
kanye are you saying that when if you
have it in your mind to kill someone
you're not well you're not willing to
drive to hollywood for it
not past the city border if it's down
the street it's so convenient you almost
have to kill him
lazy ass
and then what does he do this he posted
this he said what's this guy's address
i believe his name is david pollock
originally from atlantic city brooklyn
he lived in apartments his whole life
with others
this is what he posted
just what's this guy's address
well that's uh that's pete's friend who
posted those texts
wait which one the top one so first he
was asking what that guy's address was
and he posted that and then he posted
what dl hewley's address was too david
[ __ ] is the guy who posted the pete
text he was trying to find out where
everyone lives who was tough oh also he
was trying to find out like pete's
friend's
info right and then posted that pokemon
okay so this isn't related to huey just
not this first one though so this was
all in the same like series so kanye
posted an image
of him asking someone
for pete's friend's address yes and he
showed his address
i think he blacked it out but just
barely so he blocked it out
yeah we didn't what the [ __ ] still crazy
he is enduring during him posting all
this stuff he was also posting videos
like complaining that
he
as a black man i guess or i don't know
what else but like he's not being given
the opportunity to be a father to his
kids and like he's posting [ __ ] like
this
and also saying like why do i not have a
say with my kids right while he wants to
find somebody's address right and he's
posting it to millions of millions of
cult like fans are you sure this is
about he lost it or this is about pete's
friend because here in the comments
kanye said dl huey is a pawn that was a
different post
oh these are different from the same one
album okay yo this comment is insane he
said this is about d.l hewley he says
he's a pawn i know a king not supposed
to address upon but i address everything
and i'll and i find diel's address so
don't speak on me or my children i can
afford to hurt you
how is he not [ __ ] being kicked off
it's illegal yeah no i mean he's
actively [ __ ] threatening to hurt
people constantly yeah they suspended
him for 24 hours but if he wasn't
a mega famous celebrity he would be
[ __ ] gone for that
crazy zuckerberg knows he got to take
any w he can because his his websites
are dying
um you cannot literally threaten he's
literally threatening him he says i will
hurt you
yeah
that's illegal
so do you have the clip of what dl said
he was also
complaining about the fact that his
daughter is on tick tock
and he posted a screenshot of her from
the tick tock to his instagram like a
also like a bad
screen grab of her not a flattering one
or you know i don't know not bad but
like just like is posting a picture of
her from that tick tock that he's
complaining about yeah to his instagram
and talking about her in social media
right so what are you do you really care
about your daughter or are you just
trying are you putting her in the middle
of it yes she clearly doesn't care about
her about her
it's just crazy so here's dl comment
that made kanye want to kill him
is there a timestamp
okay kanye and kim sure uh
you know i felt it was kind of you know
in the beginning it was somewhat funny
seeing him just post
all the stuff about kim and pete
davidson and everything else like that
but
as it's beginning to drag on he's really
really terrorizing his woman online it's
never been funny well you know i mean he
put like the marvel posters so i find it
kind of amusing there's definitely a
comedy slant to what he was doing at one
point but then it's like
all right you're telling people to you
know they want beat up p davidson you
know he got him a chokehold he's
reposting all these text messages
it's like 20 posts a day i just never
the difference between him and the other
dude get restraining orders on them it's
hundreds of millions of dollars right
because he bought a house across the
street that's not from her house listen
i don't i think that i've watched too
many times when things like that happen
and a woman or somebody's not believed
and then things escalate yeah
he is stalking her you could think it's
cute if it was my daughter i'd do
something about it i don't think it's
funny i think that you can't write a
beat so good that you get to do these
things oh that's a good point
that's it and even even the interviewer
is like
it's not that funny it's like no no no
it's way worse than that that's what i
was trying to say when i was saying like
i see all kinds of people that i even
know liking his stuff it's like like
pause for a second and think what you're
liking you know
what you're thinking is amusing
this guy's actually spitting facts
he's like there's way too many times
women don't believe and then [ __ ] gets
crazy
and i also love what he said about
there's no beat you can write make you
[ __ ] all this okay heidi laughs it
off because they said well she showed
her ass all the time and he's this and
he's that and stuff at a certain point
if
it is not unusual for men like that the
only the difference between having a
restraining order is about 20 hits and a
couple of hundred million dollars i just
don't think it's funny i think that that
that kanye wouldn't get no [ __ ] at all
if he didn't write no hits you know that
like he's not the kind of you know
like he counts on the [ __ ] that he this
mystique right and in the end she got
just as much bread as she as she did
yeah and why talk to him pete davidson
is described like i don't get what the
point of threatening him like if you if
you threatening to do this [ __ ] your
woman all they gonna do is [ __ ] her
harder
and she chose him obviously it's enough
now i feel bad he's not forcing himself
on this woman and and okay you know what
interviewer shut up
stop talking
let's let the comedian talk i'm way more
interested in that divorce kanye
she said i've had enough and who with
four kids and a sec okay stop
that must have been a very i know people
are probably gonna make fun of me for
being for
that but okay whatever
say what you want but this guy's killing
me long decision because it's like
there's four kids involved well four
kids when you on so public assistance is
a lot different than four kids when you
got half a b right but at any point i
think any woman wants to have her
nuclear family together and i think that
when a woman like look you talking to a
dude have been married 37 years and i
know my woman has had enough of me at
times right i get it i understand that
and i would want
my family i understand that too but if
you want your family stop doing the [ __ ]
you did that made her leave
right which is what you're doing more of
how about take your medicine
you know what
all that all that wild [ __ ] you were
doing that got her be different i'm
gonna be normal
i'm just gonna take my medicine and see
the [ __ ] world right and stop doing
the crazy [ __ ] that exhausted her
that's at a certain point when you get
in your 40s when a woman gets in her 40s
and you getting in your 40s all that
[ __ ] that was fun
it's exhausting
[ __ ] you know what how about that
crate be normal
i gotta say he's pretty on point eh good
man i can see why i pissed connie off
because actually he was 100 right yeah
cam
uh look can we get dl hughie on the
podcast please uh
that's not happening
on it
we could ask
do you think he really wants to just
come on and talk about kanye
doubtful yeah
so okay shout outs to uh dale hewley i
guess he did go in pretty hard i thought
he went in less hard but he went hard
but he was 100 right yeah yeah one point
like how you not even go to address what
he said just post a picture of you
asking for his address or whatever or
saying like i can hurt you like i'm
sorry bro we live in america that's
[ __ ] free speech you [ __ ] coward
what a [ __ ] loser he is
what a loser this man's exercising his
free speech right he's not saying
anything crazy anything unfair and you'd
be like i'm gonna hurt you i'm sorry but
you sound like you'd fit more in that
like [ __ ] russia north korea or china
lawsuit bro
[ __ ]
kanye
that's a [ __ ] who the [ __ ] would
like that this post psychos nine minutes
67 000 likes
the comments are so crazy too i just
what drives me crazy
drives me nuts too i just banned
somebody in our chat who was spamming
that
well
kim's been divorced three times and this
is kanye's first divorce so something
about this doesn't add up
wait kim's been divorced three times i
don't know that who gives a [ __ ] i'm who
gives a [ __ ] exactly but i'm just okay
defends this one
a man related
defend him saying he wants to hurt
someone for saying what we just watched
he says i can afford to hurt you
the man thinks he has money so he can do
anything he wants
for making shitty gap [ __ ]
jackets that nobody wants
bro every time i see one one of his
gap jackets i'm like that [ __ ] looked
dumb as hell
you heard that what
why do you look embarrassed
do you have that jacket yeah i've had it
i'm not the jacket no no no i'm sorry i
have the hoodie the shoes
the shoes are what what are you talking
about i have the hoodie not the jacket
oh the hoodie i like okay okay
you told me you like this no i like the
hoodie okay the jacket the jacket is
stupid it looks like a big garbage bag i
saw it posted on reddit where people
were like man all these people trying to
look like
kanye looks so stupid with like the rain
boots and the jacket
they look like
[Applause]
[Music]
the hoodie i like baby
it's sick okay do you wear it a lot i do
but it it it does look kind of stupid i
mean it's nice it's it's nice but like
it's really short it is really small
yeah so and i have it an extra large so
i have like a belly shirt here but then
it's like really long arm so i have to
be very selective with my outfits when i
wear it god you really got to be skinny
to wear that too
it's it's almost short like a crop
hoodie
yeah
i get it's like some people being
interested in that silhouette
but the massive sale i don't get at all
like who the [ __ ] would actually wear
and you'd have to be really fit and like
really stylish and know how to like air
it
the yeezy slides i will defend till i
die they are so ugly but they are the
most comfortable shoes i've ever worn i
won't challenge you on that yeah i got
no problem with the shoes
yeah this guy's funny though actually
it's good
and then keane goes after more people
he's going after trevor noah
uh
oh this is what got instagram to suspend
him not him saying i have enough money
to hurt you if you don't stop talking
about me how the [ __ ] is that allowed
mark zuckerberg you're [ __ ] in the
head bro this is proof that facebook is
going under because he's so desperate
for his platform not to die that he's
leaving [ __ ] like this up i'm making
meats now smoking these meats
what is that who is that is that you
maybe no no that's not me that's the
jacket i sent it a while ago just took
forever to process
oh
the easy gap check the discord if you
want to show it i mean that's not the
worst picture i've seen of it it's it it
does look dumb but i've seen worse look
at the back it looks like way too big
horrible
it's so voluminous
dumb
it doesn't look fashionable it looks
like
worn out
like super worn out
and way too big
do you agree either what's your vibe i'm
not a fan of this jacket
the one thing i will say about kanye's
clothing that i do like though is that
it's original and adventurous he like
takes the chances yeah to do new stuff
which is really hard to do in fashion
if i'm going to compliment look
we're not talking about his uh
his
career right now
and his achievements right
just saying
a lot of people think oh i like the
clothes so much so i have to support him
uh threatening to kill people
yeah that team [ __ ]
it's not
you can separate the two
yo those slides are sick let's [ __ ]
kill dl huey
[Laughter]
[ __ ] that guy that dude big you'll [ __ ]
that guy connie made the slides i like
uh so tr so what the [ __ ] did he say
about trevor noah that got him suspended
how bad was this
he said let's see he posted this trevor
noah
all in together now
wait what's blurred out
he's calling him
a uh
c word but not
not that c word the other c word
can you type it in discord
i didn't talk about
cracker oh god that's horrible i didn't
know what it meant
that word racism it's kind of a it's old
school that's an old school that's a
deep cut american racist there was a big
screen where they got banned for saying
that not too long ago he didn't know
what it meant either really and he got
banned
so why is kanye using it wait so that's
the one that got it bad not threatening
people i don't get it yeah the threat is
worse yeah the threat is i mean i don't
know what's worse because i don't know
like he's a black guy using a racial
slur against another black guy it's rude
it's disgusting but it doesn't come
anywhere close to literally saying i'm
gonna [ __ ] i could afford to hurt you
that's like legal [ __ ] that's like
illegal right am i wrong no
obviously their enforcement is like way
out of whack over on instagram because
well and we know why i don't know it
if you're
giant on the platform you get a pass on
a lot of [ __ ] well the britney [ __ ] was
proof of that man she was basically
posting straight up nudes and
instagram's like this is fine when they
banned people like huge accounts for
like just right reminder
like perceived nudity kind of stuff
brittany's back did you see oh is she
yeah i knew it
i knew she gave me her account
she deleted her account holy [ __ ] maybe
in her new
sure enough she's back
we have to wrap it up soon where's our
damn food though
is it here uh sam's almost back okay it
was pretty busy she said okay
let's see what brittany's up to
it's all about
like i can't even show this [ __ ]
honestly
some of the stuff on her page
so i'm reading this comment somebody's
explaining i guess so
not not to speak on black issues but it
is it is used by black people to say
that other black people aren't really
black oh really
is that what he was basically saying
about trevor i know it was used that way
i guess i mean
could be true for noah is south african
he was born in africa i i think that he
qualifies as a black man but not
according to kanye apparently not if you
don't support kanye yep yeah
uh steve harvey emptied the ring dude
no
yeah i dare you to come after steve
harvey
pull up man you know i just sat with you
before but i said with that brother many
times pull up
it ain't what you want i'm telling you
yo steve harvey's telling him to pull up
steve harvey's a gangster dude he's not
playing around at all that mustache
don't play games kanye yo if y'all do
get to scrapping all my cash on dl you
have no idea uh yeah you have new ideas
you've been a lawyer you've been uh
you've been a little
uh
political
socially conscious rapper uh oh
we're from an ass whooping air
not the whole totally different thing
yeah we're from a whole nother area
you can come out of my house in
calabasas
yeah
he lives in town yeah come on man back
up yeah that's my guy
no he got too much
yeah is this the new tupac versus biggie
is this the new coast is this the new uh
beef that's gonna tear apart
hip-hop as we know it
pull up steve harvey says
i mean i hope not because both of those
guys wound up dead
you know what i mean like right
[Music]
right
shout out to uh dan
shout out to dan thank you keemstar
uh kim claps back shh
kim posted on instagram that her
daughter had pins in his backpack and
did not here let me see
this kid he's out of his mind dude yeah
he was posting all this stuff
i hate when he talks about his kids
like this
this was on my daughter's backpack when
i was allowed to see her last week this
is why i got go so hard for my family i
am wired to protect my family at all
costs as the priest of my home don't
worry
northy northy god is still oh because
there's an alien is that demonic yeah
what is
i think yes i think just because there's
an alien on our backpack
i don't understand
oh it shows daddy
mommy and alien maybe
i guess some religious people don't
believe in aliens because there can only
be life on our planet right
according to christianity does the
audience know i feel like we're missing
something it could be a reference to
pete maybe
oh no because the alien
still alive so it seems to me like just
about the alien
yeah it's definitely about the alien but
i mean he can interpret this a million
ways i mean who cares i don't i don't
think there's any definitive thing
connie has a song about aliens i don't
think it's any
i love the commercial go like nothing
wrong with protecting your loved ones
and be like yeah but what the [ __ ] is he
talking about
like obviously there's nothing wrong
with that
you're the one bringing it to the public
forum why are you even posting about her
why are you showing me what her backpack
looks like and
this is her personal life what do you
want from all of us to say about it
right if you're the one who cares about
her so much
why are you even saying all this and
putting it up on your instagram
just go talk to a therapist kim owned
him she said please stop with this
narrative you were here just this
morning picking up the kids for school
[ __ ] own dude
but it sucks parents your parents are
arguing online yeah
well it's not really parents it's him
kim hasn't said pretty much anything
right except that well now kim she's
she's also getting involved in a way
that that is a little weird she just put
out the new trailer for the new uh
kardashians yeah
and the song she's using in the
background is a kanye song yeah and
she's building it up like this season's
gonna be so wild yeah it's all kanye
stuff it was at the during the bachelor
oh yeah and she's like is you getting
the text from pete
yeah and i was like oh my god you guys
are really yeah just to leverage your
show like we're pretty shameless yeah
that's good
that's what i'm saying that's one thing
there's no good guys because up until
then kim didn't say anything and i was
like nice good for her no she's saving
it for the show yeah
yep
and how much did they pay for that
commercial it was like during the
bachelor
uh season finale that the whole world
was watching they're hoping and then the
host was like let me just cut to my girl
kim kardashian and then they played this
yeah was it integrated oh yeah they
played like a different conference they
never did that yeah it didn't make sense
like i was like why are they doing this
yeah totally and then yeah it had a lot
of the peat drama
gross
talk about club [ __ ] now he's on the
reality show
i'm not down it's my job as an
interviewer to ask about the tattoo
everyone said because he posted this uh
selfie sort of uh right and and there's
they're reading into it saying that
there's a tattoo that says kim
um yeah he has a few tattoos a few cute
ones you know that he got um but this
one is a did she really pull up to ellen
in full latex
what is this a bdsm conference i mean i
don't know it down she was wrapped in
balenciaga like yellow duct tape the
other day she was going to an award that
was for the fashion show at least that
was like a statement did you see the
video for walking in it she couldn't
walk
because it looks all like slick and [ __ ]
in the photo and then you see her
walking
it's not that one the kim one isn't a
tattoo it's actually a branding
like a
as soon as you say branding i hear red
flags
it's embarrassing why even share that
like it's not cool it's embarrassing the
word branding alone you should be like
red alert right she likes it i know
she's liking it it's weird i gotta say i
know we're we're not
too keen on ellen on this show either
but her reaction to him saying this is
really [ __ ] wait i thought ellen was
i was in yard stare i'm gonna go back to
capture the reaction but i thought ellen
was canceled what is this uh the the i
believe this is the last season of ellen
like they're doing he's still pulling
monster guests [ __ ] oh well i mean it's
they said it's being canceled though is
that true that's what i'm saying is it
it's not being renewed
this will be the final season of that
it's not that one the kim one isn't a
tattoo it's actually a branding
like a
branding
because let me explain it because
okay fair enough you know steve harvey
every ghost he goes what's one thing
what's one cylinder shape thing you put
in your body
and then anytime someone says
inappropriate
he does this
yeah so that's ellen schtick too fair
enough
yeah i wanted to do something that was
really different because like okay first
tattoo we got i was like oh so cute
thank you oh my god you know second
whatever i'm like oh that's so cute but
like that's what tattoo people do right
like they get tattoos of what's going on
in their life prove your loyalty to me
tattoo is nothing you need to feel pain
then
wait back back back up special you said
first tattoo
so he has three tattoos of you
sounds like this is like the third
so the first tattoo was you said kind of
cute so yeah
is it your name or is it like a little
branding is my name right the other ones
are like cutesy things i think my
favorite one
it says here it says my girl is a lawyer
and that one's really cute wow wow
delusional
she's pete's really buying the house i
know she was studying to be a lawyer but
she's not a lawyer right i don't
remember she failed the bar a bunch of
times but she passed the baby bar yeah
okay well i [ __ ] uh okay so i guess
she's a lawyer
the baby bar doesn't make you a lawyer i
don't know anything about that i just
knew that the baby bar
didn't sound like the ball i don't
really know
a baby
a baby bar
i think it's a practice exam
when does she do the grown-up yeah you
know talk to me when she passes the bar
here apparently this was a big
discussion because of this clip is kim
kardashian a lawyer now no kim is not
yet a lawyer however she's one step
closer to becoming one as she recently
passed the baby bar exam oh yeah well i
scored a [ __ ] 200 when i pulled with
my
with the [ __ ] bumper bowling [ __ ] on
too so i'm going to become a pro bowler
now
[Laughter]
right it's given after the first year of
completing law school
so yeah just seeing where you're at one
year she's nice she's never getting a
lawyer
either you gotta get a tattoo say my
husband's a pro bowler you scored a 200
with the bumper rails
oh yeah that's amazing that one's really
cute yeah wow okay so so my girl is a
lawyer and then what's the other one
there's a few all right all right all
right but when you say branding so like
literally like an iron thing yes went on
to his body yes to brand kim yes that's
embarrassing
yeah it's embarrassing i want to talk
about it
well you you are a brand
when you think about it wow because it's
like you i don't know like i
i just think he was like i want
something that's there that i can't you
know get rid of my tattoos because he's
in the process of getting rid of his arm
cats
and his neck hats so he's like i don't
want to be able to get rid of it or to
cover it up he's a girl i like it my old
cats i definitely want to get rid of
them
but i want something that i can never
cover up i don't like it why is she
doing this also you know that you chose
to share this story of course she gave
that story to
is like
here's my story that i want to talk
about could it be because he had the
ariana tattoo
and like now he has so she has a one
upper right like yeah you can't remove
this one yeah his next girlfriend he's
going over knowing what's happening with
kanye right now do you really need to
share this
story
and add fuel to the fire no it's not
it's gross i hate it it's still not the
worst tattoo he has
that's true this man this guy gets
tattooed for nothing bro so don't
don't feel flattered
love the details white on her pearl
necklace
this is a christmas gift
for his hero hillary i'm sorry but he's
such a try hard
i wanted to get a tattoo of my
hero hillary clinton
i'm just chilling in cedar rapids
wait he wanted to get her a christmas
gift that's so arrogant
no he says wanted to get hillary clipped
in a christmas kit so i tapped it so i
got a tattoo of my hero oh that's true
i didn't read it like that until now
thanks for being such a badass and one
of the strongest people in the universe
oh she even responded thanks pete
what are you doing later
[Laughter]
this makes it significant less awkward
that i've had a pete davidson tattoo for
years but seriously i'm honored merry
christmas my friend
that would be kind of interesting if you
started [ __ ]
hillary i mean she's famous
she's one of the most famous women in
the world
without a doubt
yeah i feel like that would be like the
top of the the ladder for him you think
so i think he's just i think it was you
what about angel angela merkel
i mean yeah
she actually she actually ran a country
unlike hillary for a while a long time
very influential
dude what the [ __ ] look at the drip look
at the drip on these two why is she
wearing that bro
what is she doing
they're doing the water
ridiculous and her hair the way they do
her hair yeah like it does it not move
walk of shame
doing the walk of shame they're leaving
the hotel together people they're in
front of my watching in the back
would be funny bill clinton started
tweeting about
speedy
yeah that'd be good
i don't know what is she wearing is that
like
what are you doing
anyway back to kim and i just wanted it
like there as like a scar
on me
wow well it's faster too than just
sitting for a tattoo just to get branded
i got to think about this
[Laughter]
um we're going to take a break well
allen's off her [ __ ] she missed like a
lot of opportunities to say something
funny about that
you don't insult the
kardashians know well they won't come on
your show
and get those ratings but they okay
ellen play nice
so let's see oh and then kim she's she
got slammed
for saying some really dumb [ __ ] bro
put this out what an obnoxious [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm sorry but i hate it
it's just it's disgraceful to say this
it's way too tone-deaf it's insulting
best advice i thought you don't use the
v-word i know i'm sorry i was shocked
that you said yeah but
i'm sorry
watch this clip
it's just disgusting
i have the best advice for women in
business get your [ __ ] ass up and
work
really that's the best advice you've got
specifically for women too
women just they don't want to work
i mean i've seen so many good responses
to this but talk about the most
privileged person that ever lived
telling people to get up off their ass
and work
it seems like nobody wait that's that's
not the full clip where's the full clip
didn't you pause it or
no it went to like a commercial i was
like [ __ ] up here
here this is the whole thing
get your [ __ ] ass up and work
it seems like nobody wants to work these
days you have to go through you are dead
[Applause]
i think this is highly calculated i
think they're saying this
to get publicity i don't i think she
really believes that i don't think so i
don't get i don't think people i don't
think you can plan like viral moments
like that
like i don't think millionaires they
have staff
writing this yeah
i think
usually you can but this family can you
know no no no
she believes that
and what you're saying makes it worse it
wasn't like a spur of the moment thing
oh for sure why would she want to be
my messaging let's let's workshop this
messaging i want to let the world know
that i think that people no but it's
like i want to say something that is
going to be perceived as stupid so that
people will talk about it yeah fully
good
think think the other way around
wouldn't these rich people have people
saying that's a bad thing to say that's
going to be no because they have a bunch
of yes people around them look they're
kanye is surrounded by yes people i'm
sure she does too he thinks it's smart
and i mean have you ever tried working
with like an agency those people don't
know [ __ ] about nothing like you're
talking to
i still believe that that look i'm very
like i agree that they have
they do do stuff like that especially
with the show
but i think she genuinely thinks she's
being smart right now they're doing an
interview for variety i mean
she's think she's being [ __ ] deep
yeah i
fully believe let's do let's do a poll
sure yeah let's see what the chat says i
think i've even thought about this whole
thing being fake with kanye that's very
crazy to say i know but no not what
she's fake [ __ ] pete davidson huh
like
maybe that no
i mean that would be even further but
but i've i've thought these things and i
think it's possible i hate i have two
loves so let me
what
i'm with love i agree i don't want to
say too much because i'm not going to be
canceled this weekend but yeah i think
some of it was planned i'll stop it with
that not being canceled business because
both sides are gaining publicity and of
course pizza but
drama all the time and we've been in
drama and we've been accused of it too
and it's like you really think we would
fake that it's always so real
and like yeah both sides are gaining
because everybody's talking about you
but you're going through hell when
you're in the drama trust me trust me
people they don't people don't calculate
this [ __ ] i think the situation's real
but maybe the timing the timing is so
strange when they have a new season
i don't think i i i don't think so i i
think at least within the kanye side of
things
he is he just sold an album and his stem
player thing he sold for a couple
million dollars but i think that
that ties into his whole sort of
without going too deep into it his
mental situation where he's ramping up
tying it to his art
as he's promoting all that stuff it all
kind of converges and that's why the
last like four albums he's had like
controversy around that time
it's sort of the pattern of how
his his mental state may be acting at
the time so it may seem calculated but i
believe that he is
you know going through some stuff see
that that's a great theory
and that makes sense to me
but to say that kim calculated this i
don't know i mean
i don't know what how to explain that
thinking that you guys have
it's like overly paranoid i mean i just
don't think the world is that set up and
you want to believe it but it's not it's
just not she really thinks she's being
deep yeah not so much that i believe it
just that i've like love said i've had
these thoughts not so much that i
believe it but
there isn't
i don't think there's out there like
pr geniuses that are
they can calculate so much it doesn't
exist they're [ __ ] whenever we've
tried to talk to anybody like that or
work with it's like you you really
learned that you know way better than
all of them there's no teams there's no
pr teams thinking of genius [ __ ] to get
our attention all day they're morons
yeah they're all morons
there's no there's no conspiracy
listen to this
get your [ __ ] ass up and work
it seems like nobody wants to work these
days you have just true you have to
surround yourself with people
that want to work she really feels that
superior
she feels like the reason she's
successful is because she works harder
than everyone which a lot of really rich
people think because they're [ __ ]
delusional
they don't want to look at the privilege
that got them there and they need to
rationalize why it's okay that they have
a billion dollars and then they drive by
homeless [ __ ] people in the street
and and why they shouldn't give a [ __ ]
about them because they don't work
get your [ __ ] ass up and work
it seems like nobody wants to work these
days yeah
you have to surrender that's so true
with people
that want to work have a good work
environment where everyone loves what
they do because you have one life no
toxic work environments
and show up and do the work get your
[ __ ] ass up and work
i
that wasn't that wasn't improvised
i'm saying it stuff like this
i feel like sometimes can be fake and
like manipulated for example also the
here's a better question love do you
think that she believes what she's
saying
see uh i'm just putting the thought out
there i think there's a possibility but
that's what's really these things happen
it may be scripted they may have con you
know concocted it of like oh what's
really going to piss people off but does
she believe what she's saying i mean
yeah i think i don't know anything for
fact then it really doesn't i mean
if if she believes that it doesn't
matter i don't think she would say it to
piss people off if she believed it right
i'm just saying that
i'm just saying uh it's pretty split
it's 50 just saying it's 50 50 55 saying
that it was just off the cuff uh 45
saying it was uh calculated i feel like
how do you go through the world thinking
that all this stuff is
people are out there thinking of how to
manipulate you it's just not the case
i'm telling you sometimes it is but the
world is just not that functional i'm
telling you it's all everything
like this but this is the most like
famous family in the world it doesn't
matter they're they're not confident it
doesn't matter again i'm not saying for
sure like we've seen enough to tell you
that like
if if we had a friend involved in drama
if we were
it's like
nobody could have predicted it and it's
not like anybody was faking it it's
always as real as when you see it and
you guys have been through it so again
like you guys have
always used to faking it friends have
been accused of faking it
it's not it's all and when you're in it
you're like by yourself there's no like
pr guru that is going to come by and
explain to you how to get out of the
drama here's what you need to say it's
like nobody knows you can hire a crisis
actor but they're [ __ ] incompetent
too but i mean that's like for
for like logan paul suicide 4 yeah when
you really are out of words and you need
someone to help you put like a human
message out there right yeah
because you can't even be like human at
the moment yo these i mean it's like
it's like 911 was an inside job thinking
they're they're not people are not that
competent
nobody is planning that it's just not
possible that people are not compounded
i'm not using you
okay i'm not accusing you of that i'm
just speaking to this thought that
people are having or it's like oh it's
fake oh it's planned oh it's fake i mean
it's the same skeptic it's the same
paranoia in a way that leads to really
crazy conspiratorial thinking i'm not
accusing you guys of that obviously
there's a huge difference between the
two
but
there is not crazy explanations out
there for everything it's just a dumb
she's just
okay maybe she i mean people want to
give her credit and say she's so smart
and stuff is she
well listen i would never accuse like a
person of this
like who who can be damaged from me
saying that but the fact is that these
are like multi-billionaires so
i'm a bit uh
yeah i'm not sure that's happening is
what i'm saying
you know
they're not going to care trust me
that's my point yeah
i don't think kim cares no the reason
i'm saying that is because he was saying
that you've been in similar positions
with friends and stuff
i would never like accuse anyone but the
kardashians of that because yes
billionaires if that makes sense sorry
if i'm not no it makes sense
of their own
no i i'm just
because i've been seeing people say too
and i just keep thinking to myself like
i i don't know i feel like there's no
way but
who really knows i don't know
i know kim wouldn't
i know
she just dumb
or entitled or delusional or so
privileged she doesn't know what it's
like to to not have infinite resources
and wealth and opportunity where you can
just be like i have an idea i want to
make skim i want to make a tights that
um
that sculpt your body like me
and then and then like of course you
have the money to hire all the best
people in the industry and those people
want to work with you because they the
nose can make a lot of money
what the [ __ ] who says she's smart she's
famous it's easy to make money when
you're famous
it's easy to make money when you're rich
it's very easy it's as easy as uh
pump and dumping uh crypto to your fan
base well see they weren't working hard
enough yeah the people who the people
who bought the the coin nobody wants to
work these days
yeah uh
shall we continue she's being sued for
pumping up uh she's being sued by her
workers
well they tried to work hard enough
she's like not hard enough hard enough
she's being sued
uh
for
failing to pay overtime and legally
mandated breaks
amongst other poor labor child child
labor violations too this is these are
just her current
lawsuits wait where did you hire
children
that people
underage were working at her house
at her house yeah this is this lawsuit
is about domestic workers these are like
housekeepers and stuff that are suing
her
what yeah
it's good stuff
listen you ladies need to want to work
harder that means skipping lunch and not
getting paid overtime because you should
be happy that you're here
girl boss uh in 2006 and 2007 you can
pull this one up dan she stole 120 000
by making unauthorized purchases
including
for items in two kardashian family owned
clothing stores dash and smooch was
settled out of court kim kardashian
abused my credit card single mother
manager alleges him and her siblings
spent 120 000 without permission
the story is [ __ ] crazy and the
weirdest thing is it do you guys
remember brandy the r b singer yeah it
was very popular back in the day it was
her mom that they stole the money from
well they they people just wanted to get
up and work that's right that's crazy
right right right that's the connection
wait right
that's ray jay's mom so they were
stealing money from ray jay's mom
[ __ ] degenerate
[ __ ] why would they it says cl it says
kardashian siblings chloe courtney and
robert junior she apparently was her
assistant at some point and was given a
credit card to make purchases for her
job and then used the credit card to
just spend a bunch of money at her own
family store to essentially steal the
money
awesome and there was a lawsuit but it
got settled out of court
awesome
seems like nobody wants to work
and of course uh
oh yeah you got to read some of the
quote tweets are pretty great to this
i was an editor on the kardashians app
in 2005 in la where days nights and
weekends could only afford groceries
from the 99-cent store called out sick
more than once because i couldn't put
called out sick more than once because i
couldn't put gas in my car to get to the
office and was reprimanded for
freelancing on the side
david cross no i have the best advice be
born in a rich family get a [ __ ] ton of
plastic surgery film and then release
the orchestrated sex tape now that was
orchestrated obviously
parlay that planned notoriety into a
reality show exploiting your younger
sisters and voila
easy peasy and now kids apparently yep
time to get off my [ __ ] ass and spend
3 500 of my dad's money on shoes when i
was younger i worked in my dad's office
when i was there i discovered ebay and i
loved shopping i had to be on a budget i
didn't have credit cards how do i figure
out how much how to make this a business
i remember i bought these milano blanc
blonics
i i don't i need more context here
i worked i worked my little college ass
off for free for kimberly so i better
get some
addendum in here saying except celine
she was amazing
why does she even have free labor like
internships please
um
biggest crime of all
elo
so natural
get your [ __ ] ass up and work
get your [ __ ] ass off and work
okay now
yo she looks like
that's kind of like
uncanny valley creepy
so there you go [ __ ] them all let god
sort them out
find god
find god kim and kanji and eat
all right the food's here guys have a
great weekend we actually did the
[ __ ] kim
yeah
we're gonna do it wow how long it takes
have a great weekend guys appreciate
your drinking weekend i'm gonna eat some
boyegas take care be good stay blessed
sub update
we're above 3 million
by 38.
by 38
it'll be below by by monday it'll be
below by the next 20 minutes what can i
do not say it
i might wait i thought i'm supposed to
no you can't say a specific number when
you're so close because then they're
going to troll you and drop at least 40.
now they're going to win
you made it worse
all right guys i got to eat thank you
jimmy
they said we wouldn't come back but we
always do embrace from the ashes like
the phoenix on the flex back to two
[Music]
you're watching h to the three three